podcast and well it is off the rails and
we're pretty much looking to guarantee
that today
March 22nd a beautiful yet rainy day
fantastic show planned here today so
good glad you guys are going to be here
uh sponsored by gamer sup who we love so
well and PayPal honey we love them okay
now on Monday we took a vote and the
people of the audience said uh and uh
what was a 10 point spread
which you know in politics that's a huge
win
uh that Jimmy should be here
and Jimmy is here
The Outlaw is in town
give me
how does it feel to be in the studio of
the great H3 podcast I'm honored and I'm
also uh if you guys share that other
screen I'm actually in my dental office
at the same time there I am you're both
you're at work right now so at the same
time thanks to can you throw the mic a
little bit closer yeah to h3's beautiful
office design
you like what we did there with uh Mr
warmth yeah and pinks and my My Magazine
cover yep can I ask you a question is a
dentist the same person that does root
canals yes because I heard that there's
two different people well a specialist
is an endodontist but GPS do do they can
do it also so in what case would you go
to the specialist harder cases in molar
root canals mostly okay so there there's
a case where they're
their curved curve roots
difficult cases you would refer them to
a we do easier ones and send out hard
ones because then the patient gets it
done right and then we do the crown and
there's no and problem when you
reference them uh do you get a kickback
from that no we have relationships with
Specialists and like I needed a root
canal done last year obviously I didn't
get charged because I have a
relationship with the specialist I said
too but I don't I don't
take a kick back okay I'm just saying
hey I'm just asking chocolate milk
that's right yeah hey Jimmy what's so
anyway let me set the parameters okay
on the show yesterday we had a
conversation about
you wanting to have dinner with us but
only if you could film it and then Dan
brought up this interesting concept he
says hey Jimmy
maybe it's not a character when you go
on the street and harass people maybe
that's who you really are right which I
had told him I'm not really like that in
fact even Danny yeah
one of my social media people said you
know they need to know how you are
because I've been with you the last few
days you're like normal when we eat out
you're just doing your social media
we're talking what to do and you're not
like that but I said I gotta have Dan
Dan know that dance character yeah but
I'm I'm not really that person that's my
character well we're putting you to the
test today I know I know you talk so the
so we were toying with a few Concepts
um on Monday I was thinking of having
you eat a spicy chip but I think you
might actually die from that like Rubble
Mrs my stomach won't handle it yeah and
the other thing is FICA fish do you how
are you I don't even know we couldn't
even get the fika fish apparently it's a
rare commodity the other one was to show
you the prolapse video which I'll do I
will do that okay I don't know what that
is but okay yeah okay and and but so
I think the big theme here we're going
with is
you can sit in on the show
but
and here's the challenge to you you
cannot tell a single joke or
attempt to be funny
in any way flavors
are the rules uh clear to you yeah okay
Zach and you told me
and if you have three strikes if you
violate the rules three times you will
be ejected from the show okay I got your
mic will be muted Security will escort
you out okay
flavors we're dogs though
do you really like Pink's Hot Dogs yeah
are you just they you got they got you
on the wall huh yeah how'd you pull that
it started when we shot in March and we
went back death noodles had me on in
November we went back to eat and the
lady remembered me and made a comment
and called Mr Pink
[Music]
Mr Pink came on the phone and and he he
said I'm glad you're there and uh gave
us shirts and hats yeah and I got his
email and I sent him a picture of me
when we shot in March where I was in
front of the counter and he actually
printed it up and put it in his
restaurant emailed me that I'm on the
wall wow then we became a relationship
thing and then when we came out we
emailed him the time we would be at
Pink's on Sunday and he was there fed us
for free gave us hats at shirts and the
whole funniest thing was today I I
walked back to my hotel right to get my
car before I come
and I'm getting my corn the waiter says
Jimmy Lee come here Mr Pink is having
breakfast in our hotel today you're
getting respect from Mr Pink yeah and Mr
Pink I went in and bought them breakfast
has he ever seen your routine he he said
to me this is what he said to me
Jimmy Lee you make my customers happy
and you're fun we love having here and I
and I have to preface that with one
other thing we were getting our nails
done the other day at a place in Beverly
Hills and Robert Ray the famous place of
surgeon walked by and with us and Jimmy
I'm fascinated but I gotta keep the show
on the rail no it's okay it's okay we
can get we can catch up uh in the big
details of it I was just going to tell
you another another story right yeah but
the thing yeah you could you know I'm
sorry where does it end Jimmy won't
Jimmy tell Ethan about your four
pedicures
[Music]
yeah go ahead
so let's start off by showing you the um
the prolapses it's all I have uh
basically as a
a challenge to you if you could thank
you win Hungerford for the 40 gifted
what a legendary uh person thank you do
you guys have the link to the uh
prolapse video please
for Jimmy DeVille yeah we have a Q we're
going to start out
um yeah just right out the gate
can you take off your glasses for this
we want to see your eyes if that's okay
thank you we want to get your Rea it's a
get your reaction on it
nobody mentioned if they like my
hairline okay
Olivia the first one up was Olivia thank
you Olivia you're definitely looking a
lot more natural well I learned finally
how to do it myself well took you well
Jimmy I'm a little dum-dum I know well
Jimmy you're 75 for Christ's sake it's
about time you learn subtract 22 off
that multiple 22. all right so roll the
prolapse video if you would please and
Jimmy uh your full attention is required
all right honey
uh that audience will not see it they'll
only see your reaction okay
okay I'm pulling it up now uh in I'm
gonna put it on the screen ready
can you see that Jimmy yes sir all right
here it is
is this covid related you as a doctor
can uh answer that for us
what's that
somebody tiny
what is this that's disgusting
yeah that's their [__] that's a
prolapsed [__] but I don't understand
what this guy's doing now
he's putting his hand in the guy's
[__] right and then he's his
intestines are coming out somebody has
some serious problems I thought I had
serious problems okay that's a joke
Jimmy you gotta just now no that's not a
joke I'm just saying whoever's now
they're what do you think about that I
think that's worse than the other part
but why
I don't understand the whole meaning of
your ass
that's a friend of the show Hunger FF is
that Dan
quite well
he's a doctor you know
I don't I don't think he understood what
he's looking at are those prescription
yeah okay so he didn't see he couldn't
see it oh these aren't prescription
these are my readers this is my homo
glasses oh okay okay put me in please
all right let's get back in the zone but
yeah you handed that well you it's a
it's a it's a sexual um
let's say genre that's gross and they
prolapse that is just gross they like
the prolapsing I've seen videos and
movies that's gross really what have you
seen what's the grossest kind of that
that before that
I don't know right
but nothing that bad right well you did
say I've seen so it seems I've seen bad
things but I mean that thing's
horrendous seems like you recalled
specific things
Jimmy's from the school of old school
like betamax porn you know like beta Max
Porn yeah
beta see I have a joke on that but I'm
not allowed to do a joke but I have a
funny joke but I won't do it it is there
it is no I'm not doing it no I'm saying
you do well that was a test that was a
test yeah yeah you skirted kind of close
so I'm gonna go ahead and do the show
if you have some kind of um
let's say you know supplemental uh
factual biographical information or
inside the subject matter then I'd like
to hear your expertise on that yeah no
joke just no be like the guest and the
commentator a little bit yeah yeah I got
you okay thanks be like Ed McMahon
okay that's your no that's Ed MC well
you're I'm just saying well Impressions
art can be perceived as trying to be
funny I'm just
just setting the ground rules here
so we have actually a great uh show here
today
really uh interesting uh setting for
Jimmy to be here too so The Tick Tock
one of the tick tock alpha males
um we've actually talked about them
before
his name is Sebastian G
he is a entrepreneur and he made a video
that went viral on Tick Tock saying
every guy in their 20s should own a
Lambo
and if they don't they need to take a
hard look in the mirror here so he's
calling in essentially I'm building up
to that but here's a refresher for you
guys who haven't seen it and you don't
have a Lamborghini you should actually
sit down and have like a serious
discussion with yourself as to why you
don't have a Lambo yup because it's I
realize now that it's so incredibly easy
and there's so much money out there and
200 Grand relative to what is out there
in circulation and what you can grab
especially now with AI tools that you
can leverage like never before 200 Grand
is Trump change so this guy so we all
watch that video
Jimmy just put a lifesaver in his mouth
and offered me one
which is
if I can suggest as a professional
podcaster I know I don't have much
ground to stand on but it's a bit of a
lip smacking type of a treat
you want one no I'm good okay was that a
joke no
no I'm being trying to be nice you
already offered me one Jimmy
yeah my Savers are pretty uh sugary yeah
our life savings for teeth
would a dentist recommend a suck on
Lifesavers sure yeah why not all good
yeah okay yeah as long as you brush
however you brush after every meal three
times a day a good problem yeah after
every meal you live it you don't just
preach it you live it yeah yeah you can
respect that and flossing at night
before I go to bed one time
right wow good her mouth dries out at
night and you're more prone to Decay so
you've lost at night good for you
yeah this is great
um
a little sprinkle in some kind of
knowledge about throughout what are the
top tips you would say to someone who
wants to preserve their teeth and gum
what's the number one thing you would
say
[Music]
to preserve your teeth and gums yeah
prevent the way
a healthy a healthy balanced diet but
limit your sugars and limit hard Foods
okay that's basic is that more or less
important than brushing and brushing and
flossing all the time and going to the
dentist every six months okay there it
is that's basic that's basic that's
basically there's more but that's just
basic things like that's basically
so anyway back to uh Sebastian G so we
all know him he made also another toy
that we all kind of viewed men want one
thing large mountain style home in the
forest by Lake Pleasant wife with no
attitude that's the part that struck me
is interesting
three to five children
that's in his house and a gym no no no
no no no no
Heaven Stone
he's just saying he fantasized about it
but the video that really captured my
attention
is this video he put on his Tick Tock
some people are really stupid where he
said he wants to come on the show
so uh I well here it is okay
now here it is
some people are really stupid Ethan
Klein is the worst person oh we all know
this he's the worst person on the planet
he wishes he was us
I would love to speak to him I'd love to
talk to him go on the podcast I would
try to change his life I don't I think
I'd have a hard time be my that'd be the
final boss if the toughest battle so so
uh Sebastian G 24 year old entrepreneur
he's calling I said dude this is a great
opportunity for me I want you to call in
and change my life have a good night so
uh he's calling in at uh two o'clock
uh he was very polite we connected and
he was very he was actually very polite
and nice and uh we're gonna send him a
zoom Link at two
okay can you believe people talk about
me on the internet like that Jimmy but
he wasn't talking nice about you not at
all no and we're having and you're
having him on yeah well he he is an
expert a self-help Guru okay is he like
an Anthony Robbins one of them
yes Anthony Robbins is that the big tall
guy that's the guy When We Were Young
backwards that started out yeah he was
one of those Tony wrote Tony wrote Tony
Robbins yeah oh Anthony was Anthony
Robbins when he started he shortened it
up yeah
yeah he's like Anthony Robbins
so he'll call in he'll maybe help us
both out you know
um so that's something I'm looking
forward to uh at the top of the show I
wanted to talk about
um
well since we're talking about the
Alphas
might as well get this out of the way
here on there's no jumper with snico
and these are guys who think being gay
is Icky
and they would they would never dream of
it uh of course Nico talked about how he
went to an orgy and dudes were licking
his balls
essentially what geez but here they are
talking about how cool how being
straight is awesome well maybe not but
you could get it wet yeah
the [__] is just like an open wound
it's a gaping hole in a woman's body
yeah and that's why I hate when women
are like I give head all the time and
these dudes don't want to eat [__] or
whatever it's like listen it's not the
same
no if I stuck this lighter in my mouth
right now which I won't uh that would be
like something a dick what what but the
lighter thing was so weird to me it's
like why are you putting a lighter now
but she won't and it's like a pit of
yeah I mean it's less fleshy tissue and
babies come out of there
periods but he continuing to the lighter
is just like it works
I'm just saying it's like it's not it's
not the same so this is the ultimate
Alpha take and what's interesting to me
is he says
[__] nasty dick not that bad
so who is gay so who is gay as the
question Jimmy
he doesn't seem like he's gay no
even though you're right what you said
it's an interesting analysis who is the
guy if you don't mind me he's no jumper
uh he's uh he's just a YouTuber yeah he
interviews people and stuff
so there you heard it from snico and uh
Adam 22 [__] is gross
but I think I just said icky it's icky
yeah [__] is icky and dicks are not
that bad to suck apparently that's a big
game man I mean that's pretty game oh
it's an interesting take to put out
there I am
gay you think it's that the a little gay
or do you think that they just are that
they look down on women that much well
what I find interesting kind of
chauvinistic to be honest right a little
bit oh thank you Jimmy well there's two
ways to look at that right one is like
he doesn't care enough to reciprocate
with his partner he's like I'll accept
all these uh favors from you but I'm not
gonna oh
I'm trying to I'm trying to I'm trying
to be delicate around Jimmy's
sensibilities
I think at the very least they should
consider sucking dick oh geez right
because and then if you think about it
because he goes just if they were my
friends that's the advice yeah no
consider it yeah you might like it yeah
because you he was about to put a
lighter in his mouth exactly but
everybody said well what about a wall
yeah yeah that'd be like such a real
clear how is that like sucking dick at
him so are they calling into
they'll be calling in as well it's just
a whole so all these people are calling
in you sucking a ding dong
everybody's calling in today
um by the way before the show we had a
whole episode trying to figure out how
to mute your phone
I know you and you have to unmute it
when I leave because I don't know how to
do it my kids aren't with me here yeah
so that's a pro that has to be a problem
no we'll fix it okay I just thought it
was interesting you never muted your
phone
nor did you even know it was a thing I
think I didn't even know yeah
that's cool
but so is it but he says he acknowledges
dick is not that gross it's actually
less gross than magina
so on one hand it is misogynistic but on
the other hand as you pointed out Olivia
sounds like options could be open that's
it that's all I'm saying there it is
maybe they should try sucking each other
off
wait that's so cute wow that is a sweet
sweet that would have been the best way
for this interview to end is them 69ing
each other right
right Jimmy I'm with you thanks buddy
thanks buddy I appreciate the backup the
backup loud yeah don't push don't push
stack
um here's a video that I want to enjoy
with you guys it really
Amazon delivery guys man they are
something aren't they
here it is at a police standoff
it seems like a dangerous situation guns
are drawn some kind of hostiles standoff
the Amazon driver
this man says I shall deliver this
package
rain Sun
sleet
shoot off hell yeah really check it out
Amazon hard at work I get it brother
Jeff Bezos so happy right now he's
delivering a package in the midst of a
scandal yes sir no kidding get after it
Jeff Bezos Eat Your Heart Out
promote this man
crazy promote him now
yes
please
oh my God
bro he's lucky didn't shoot his ass
he just delivered a package and left
yeah they took it too
he finished the job you know he got it
done that's commendable he should get a
raise yeah
this man is like hell no
I ain't got time to come back to this
house
he doesn't get paid enough to deal with
this that's amazing I'm not coming back
you know I'm serious about your work and
that is our labor of the day
he deserves we honor him we honor him
our our labor he deserves
to get paid for the value he produces
damn it hell yes hell yes Amazon
this guy's awesome we should get he's
calling in too
no yes he is we got a hold of him how'd
you get a hold of him
I don't believe I don't believe that one
the company police cars are
[__] no where was that at this man where
was it at you know I don't know but it's
like imagine pretty cool like 20 police
cars like I'd be like staying away from
it I would be leaving yeah not him he's
like Frodo at the [__] Mount Mount
Doom yeah
that was a great one man I
man I would have the drop off I didn't
even think about that I thought he was
taking it of like the scene how crazy it
was I don't know he was taking a little
delivery he was taking a photo of the
drop off who is he look at this Amazon
is this [__] that's for the app it made
it he took the picture of the cop with
the package
they stand it off holy [__] so get
written up if he doesn't
we should try to find him so we can hire
him I don't know what to do what but I
know he's dedicated yeah
CIS white male Center
boss potentially uh the world the world
will never harm you
you will never be harmed no matter what
so anyway uh we honor him labor of the
day
how do you feel about communism Jimmy
how do I feel about communism yes as a
concept
I don't know I'm not a pup fair enough
I'm I'm a capitalist guy I grew up here
I don't agree with it I mean everybody
does their own thing there it is
I don't begrudge anybody for what they
do but um I grew up in this country so
you know you bleed red white and blue
here it is I like that that's a good
answer you know you're not
it's good
if you don't know something you know you
don't have to speak on it
hey you know who Justin roilin is the
creator of Rick and Morty no
he put out a statement just now
oh yeah yeah this is going to be a big
story I guess
uh have you guys seen people talking
about this yet it just happened
right before we went live and there was
no articles or anything about it when I
Googled it but it's been about 30
minutes now so there might be oh boy uh
this sucks it's just sucky and awesome
30 minutes ago
take a look I do feel like it's a little
bit directed towards not me specifically
but people like me right who stopped
associating with him after he got he was
a friend of mine oh was okay and some
horror really horrible things came out
about him kind of like a me too style of
thing right okay
and he says um
I've always known that these claims were
false and I never had any doubt that
this day would come
I'm thankful that this case has been
dismissed so I don't have any intel
about he was tried for domestic uh abuse
I don't have any intel if it was
dismissed it may have been I don't know
it would be a very weird thing to tweet
out if it wasn't so I have to have to
assume he knows why wouldn't he just say
the case was dismissed today you know
it's like
uh
he did
this statement hold one sec this
statement comes months after NBC News
reported on broilan's legal situation it
was there the public learned royland had
been arrested in August 2020 and charged
with felony a domestic battery and false
imprisonment in California so according
to him it's been dropped although we
haven't been able to corroborate that he
says
um I'm thankful the case has been
dismissed but at the same time I'm
deeply shaken by the horrible lies that
reported about me during this process
most of all I'm disappointed that so
many people were so quick to judge
without knowing the facts based solely
on the word of an embittered ex trying
to bypass due process
and have me canceled
that it may have succeeded even
partially is shameful however now that
the legal case has ended I'm determined
to move forward and focus both on my
creative projects and restoring my good
name so like
what I'll say about this is
you know when the case came out when
people found out about this charge
against him
a lot of people most people were like
well let's see what happens because we
don't have the evidence in fact he was
um
he ca he still had his job
I think the cancellation really came
when all these DMS started coming out
you know specifically there's one where
the girls telling him she's under age
and he says that like that's all good
with him and [__] like he he's not
really addressing
the accusations that were the most
serious right that's what I'm seeing
here
um in fact he's not even trying to
refute them is he he's just said they
were horrible lies just generally not
not very specific so
you know I don't know man
you know what I mean anyone have
thoughts crickets in here
all right thank you everybody
so well once you said it I was just
intentionally
um
I I was also dealing with something else
I apologize but well the thing is I
don't want to say anything
but I've learned since those stories
come out
that
I know a little bit about this situation
I've I've learned
about who the ex is she's remained
um private
and I think it's re from what I know of
her and of this and you know what I've
heard behind the scenes of the situation
because I've obviously when this
happened I was trying to understand what
the hell is going on
I don't think it's I think it's
he says over
she he says over
that an embittered X
trying to bypass due process and have me
canceled
and I think that that's not an accurate
uh portrayal of what happened
you know more because you know the girl
you're saying I do know yeah I do is
this the underage X that you're
referring to or oh no she would no no no
okay because chat was a little confused
about that oh that was a DM that she
that's people there was a ton of DMS of
him being gross is what got him cam how
old is the guy eighth uh he's about my
age a little older a couple years older
than me and he's dealing with minor
girls yeah he's bad news that's not
important exactly figure out yeah yeah
he's 43 so yeah he's just a year older
thing well he's a favorite one year old
he was a buddy years in the past he was
we were really close actually it really
hurt it's painful
is that about people you don't think
they're one way and they end up being
one way right
it's pain it is it's been it has been
painful uh uh it won't lie I mean it's
not about me but it's hard to navigate
this kind of thing when it's happening
to your friends but this response is not
it's not good and let me just say that
that's really not a fair
characterization from what I understand
[Music]
um
I'm not I will not I'm not going to talk
about it more specifically than that but
it's [__] up I don't know man
foreign
I mean and how are we going to look past
that DM of him being like hey you're
underage can you pull that up just to
refresh
no no uh jailbait one yeah the jailbait
one he's like you're jailbait you're 17.
ah come hang out with me write a song
about tons of [__] [__] on your face
that was a different one he said
straight from Jordan that was a that was
a employee right that he
sent that one so he goes so he said
literally 100 years ago oh that was from
his podcast right but he set up
100 years ago
uh
it was little 13 year old girls if they
were built like a woman they were
getting married and having kids and now
we're going to be all precious about it
that's what he said on his podcast but
here's the this is the one that's like
come on bro
that's the dicks off one oh boy
this isn't the one made me switch off
Ian
uh does this one not have
I thought this is the one you're
referring to well anyway you guys have
all read it they're all out there
no the one the jailbait one that one's
not the jailbait one
but anyway we don't need to show it you
know I don't know I
I understand he's trying to say ah you
know [__] me dude it just sucks
yeah here it is Jimmy tell me what you
think about this one what's it say oh
yeah sorry the airport it's insane in
the membrane what time is it there 11
30. oh so so right
it's so Ray and me so Chinese
I have school tomorrow oh school
tomorrow LOL no F my life you should run
away from home and go into sex slavery
you [__] stupid uh F slur [__] he's
got problems
I thought I had problems he has problems
well histrionic is nothing yeah
histrionics I'll walk in the park it's a
walk in the park this guy's got real
problems he says would you do video game
reviews and stuff like that I bet you do
good she says yeah just playing games
and [__] then once you turn 18 you start
cam whoring
what he says to her why are you such a
jailbait what's wrong with you in that
regard you should grow older you dumb
[__]
I think you got to get rid of this guy
then he says is it cool being jailbait
does the FBI follow you around arrest
all the men you sleep with so like bro I
mean he needs to have better things to
do than that
he did that's the thing he was very busy
very creative
very very creative that's gonna ruin him
that's gonna it has if it hasn't already
it has he it has absolutely ruined him
actually yeah uh he was on the biggest
show in the world pretty much Rick and
Morty he had just released a huge video
game the guy was successful and he blew
it um he was on top of the world
probably the most the most successful
creative person you know alive at the
time how long ago was he successful like
recent no it had been going for a while
okay your kids definitely know Rick and
Morty it's like super super famous I got
you yeah
thank you by the way to Dixie namas for
the 10 gifted appreciate you Ethan we're
still beefing Kevin
who is this he did this on the members
you and Kevin have some serious beef uh
I don't know what that's about okay
that's for you two to work out also you
know that you just you just got owned
right a moment ago with the the name
that you're right now Dixie gnomus
oh Dixie gnomus
you could have just wrote dick enormous
I would have said it would have read it
out I would have just read it oh no I'm
giving people ideas
Dixie gnomis thank you Legend
yeah Kevin I don't know who the [__] you
are dude he left this message on the
members live stream yesterday it's gonna
upset him even more and then I sent you
guys the name I says wait do we know him
is this one of the yeah no it's nobody
Okay Kevin okay apparently we have beef
thanks for the money
Lawrence 21 today Zach thank you happy
birthday I'm 21. [__] you mm-hmm
I don't know the Justin thing's tough
man
really sucks
it's actually not even the first friend
I've had go through something like this
it's the first you had to be one this
bad this bad this one's really bad how
many people have have you had this
happen to a lot or just a few dude
that's got to be our third one right
it was Chris D'Elia oh who I wasn't
friends yeah we were we were friendly
you're talking to your comedians it was
just like a professional I know that
name really he was also on top of the
world and then what did he do to mess up
kind of similar stuff to be honest just
the young girls well actually I don't
know if it was similar or even worse
because he was or I don't know if I want
to say worse but he was he was doing
similar [__] it was gross well I was
reading this article and it says when
Leo DiCaprio was 22 he dated girls 22
when he was 32 he dated girls 22 when he
was 42 he dated girls 20. 48. he's still
dating girls that almost sounds like
your story but they read it except
they're 16 instead of 22. yeah well at
least they're they're always over 21
days what do you think about Leo uh
Leonardo getting older but his girl
staying the same a lot of older guys
like younger girls I mean that's been
around for years I mean and then a hotel
where I see it almost every day why do
you think older guys like younger girls
they're more attractive they're hotter
yeah they're better looking um
what do you mean fresher they're young
they're young they're a lot younger
women are more attractive than older
women right so yeah bro that's just a
high school girl that was hot as [__]
tonight
what was that what would you oh that
what the hell was that that was keemstar
yeah oh okay sorry there it is
old women are nasty would you say it go
that far see I have a funny funny joke
but I'm not allowed to do jokes I used
it on the boardwalk that you're doing
really good young woman old woman but
I'm not gonna do it don't nope don't do
it but or the situations because I'm
always writing I always have that that
little thing in the back pocket right I
have it ready but we're not shooting at
all we're not doing it today no in fact
I think you're doing great I think
people like Regular Jimmy are you guys
think uh I've ever said that well up
until about 45 seconds ago yeah
up to what I didn't hear what well I
think you saying old women are repulsive
may have I didn't say that I said
younger women are more attractive to
older guys than older women I did not
say they were repulsive right I put that
word and I've traveled all over with my
wife and in Europe it's commonplace and
and in my hotel I see it and very very
common in Europe the older guy younger
girl what is the cap in terms of like
where you find a woman to be hottest
like what age probably 20s and early 30s
early 30s anything over that is damaged
goods oh you're asking me a question I
mean you have to look at people I mean
I'm not as good looking at one when I
was young I got to do do the hair
different now and all that but when I
was young I was good looking so it's the
same for a guy too there's a lot of
older women that like younger guys would
you have sex with a woman over 35
probably probably yeah over 40.
you start pushing it when you hit it
yeah you're pushing it yeah yeah
unfuckable
well not not as good not as good looking
as when they're young
no I'm asking you're asking me I'm being
honest your honesty is what matters to
me and I appreciate it but it sucks to
be a woman doesn't it because it's like
well you know my mom told me as a kid it
was and I didn't get it but I get it now
she always said to me you know women
when they're young and they're good
looking they kind of have the World by
their balls but guys always can age
gracefully and they can always get a
young woman but as the woman gets older
they're less attractive and the guys
have it better when they're older my mom
was telling me that when I was little I
didn't under yeah and I didn't
understand that till now that I'm older
but you know she told you she told me
that and how old is your wife
my wife is
51 and
she would you say she's attractive or
very attractive yeah I have to say that
or I'm out of the will yeah do that you
know that wasn't a joke yeah that's the
truth but I've been with my wife for
years and and I met are you guys still
active yeah we're active we take walks
together and everything sure is that
what you meant
or did you actually yeah we're sexually
active yeah we take and take walks good
for you we take walks actually with the
mailman on his day off oh God not the
mail oh that's a joke Jimmy no it wasn't
I guess it was it's not it it's not it
wasn't a joke it's the truth don't push
we do we're friendly with the mailman
home and it wasn't a joke we take walks
with the me I'm going to say if it
wasn't a joke you cannot ask that that
sounds like a sexual thing no it's a no
no your wife had sex with the mailman
yeah no in fact I've heard you you you
missed you missed it Jimmy don't push no
no I'm not a fool I know when it's not a
sexual you're not walking with your
mailman stop it no the joke with the
mailman is did you ever take a walk on
your day off because he walks you
literally shot you did but it was not a
sexual one
don't you totally misunderstood don't
push don't come on I'm not an idiot
Jimmy and it's a sexual it was a joke it
wasn't a sexual joke
that's one no can I talk you can talk
but I'm saying that's one strike now
guys listen if I meet a guy and I go
what do you do he goes a mailman I said
did you ever take a walk on your day off
so that that's how that joke's intended
if it wasn't no but you were good it's
actually it's sexual no but it doesn't
matter if it's sexual you're saying you
sleep with your wife and also the
mailman you I will go for a walk
together with the mailman that's a joke
we take a walk with the family because
you walk with the mailman no the mailman
do you walk with the mailman no that's
then then enough said okay I'm done
that's one strike unless your ass is
Walking with the mailman the the joke
was a joke about the mailman had nothing
to do with sex the sex I don't care
about this sex that's not the rule okay
thank you that's one okay
keeping you on your toes there Jimmy all
right Jimbo I'm gonna thank our sponsors
then we're gonna have a call in actually
Dan can you send me the zoom link and
Discord so I'll pass it to him sure can
oh yeah absolutely you can yeah Jimmy's
gonna use the restroom already
here we'll send this to you right now
you gotta love Jimmy's honesty at the
very least he
you know what I mean like
who does here let me give you oh [__]
here send it on WhatsApp so I can copy
paste it okay
done Jimmy maybe a permit maybe
shirtless Eddie a run for his money
you know not a bad co-host not at all
you know when Jimmy pulled in today
he um got out of his car and then he put
his hands up to Ian's car and just
looked in the back window I don't know
what that was about but I would love to
ask him about that you filmed it it was
pretty cool yeah I knew he'd have an
epic entrance so I want to capture it
and then Dan I'll give you his email and
you can send it
to him there too just so he he gets it
in two spots
sounds good
here is his
email so there it is looking forward to
that
got it
okay
fantastic so let me thank our sponsors
then our wonderful sponsors yes yes I'm
talking about gamer sup that's
revolutionizing the game they drink game
Gamers rise up
I got my shaker cup
it's GG baby gamer sup
hit that I can't give up the black
cherry
so good
yeah Gamers up is changing the whole
game man
here's the thing I want you guys to know
free sample packs for the next 24 hours
wow
I'm gonna tell you I like that
wow wow
I'm gonna tell you guys right now
if you go to Gamers
gamersupps.gg H3 links in description to
get your you'll get a free sample pack
all you have to do is add it to the cart
hit checkout enter your mailing address
and enter your email address you don't
have to put a credit card you don't have
to do anything the total is zero and the
sample comes to your house
does it get
I mean
absurdly good deal it's like you can't
you just like it's all why wouldn't you
do it well usually they're like oh you
got to put in a credit card and stuff
too but they're like no just nope give
me just tell me where to send it yep you
guys know we love gamer sub we always
hit this man it's great if you're you
know trying to lose weight not drink
sugary drinks if you don't like coffee
it's a great way to get caffeine it's a
great way to hydrate it's a great great
way to get off sugary drinks they've got
tons of awesome flavors
uh different flavors
they've got all different flavors that's
true Jimmy
um I just love it I love it so much and
you know I've seen a lot of people say
Ethan how much do you love it
I so much Jimmy okay
do you think
how much do you love it I I haven't
tried it
I will now
is it like an energy drink like the
power plus x-axis
um kind of yeah thanks I love that
energy drink I guess right you can say
that yeah it's an energy drink an energy
drink it's a powder you dissolve it in
water it was a Shaker and Ice it's great
anyway but we're almost done with this
so uh anyway guys go get the free sample
I mean come on right Link's in the
description it's just so awesome I love
me some gamer sup and they're such a
great sponsor so show them some love
thank you guys I was gonna say I see
lots of people tagging me saying this
isn't something I usually try but I got
the free sample and I love it
like that soft that's soft girl did we
ever show that
the what Olivia remember that uh that
girl soft
who she tried gamer so
do we have that screenshot whatever
yeah I'll thank you to PayPal honey
love me some honey
today's episode is sponsored by honey I
love you the easy way to save when
shopping on your iPhone or computer
you know about honey Jimmy no
so great what actually it's a free
Chrome extension
you know what a Chrome extension is I'm
sorry I don't know this stuff yeah go
ahead
so if you're you know what Chrome is
okay do you know what a computer is yes
okay do you know what a web browser is
yes okay so Chrome is a web brow oh
Google Chrome Google Chrome that I do
know I apologize I know it's okay and so
on Google Chrome you can add extensions
that enhance or modify your experience
on Google on Google Chrome on Google
Chrome right one of these extensions is
called honey what does it actually do
good question Jimmy what honey does
is when you're shopping at your favorite
online store and you're at checkout it
scours the internet automatically for
the best coupon code and automatically
applies it
okay so it saves you money so it's a
valuable thing because you get an Roi on
it guess how much it cost
I see it it's 13. guess how much honey
1341. you think a honey cost well I'll
give you I'll surprise because it's not
it's not uh 1 300 for honey it's free
okay that's one that's free that's
actually savings this is something we
bought Ela bought this it's like a piece
of furniture we saved 150 149 thanks to
honey so every time you buy something
they'll throw up couponing the highest
one automatic you don't have to even do
anything that's right that's phenomenal
it is it's amazing how cities and genius
people on the computer just find
different ways to
come up with things that are valuable
that give a lot of people and then they
can make money on them yeah it's so
different than my generation everything
with us was bricks and mortar you got to
open up a store like your dad had a bike
shop I have dental offices it's so
different today it is it really is thank
but yeah I think you summarize that
great it is you know it's a metrics
you're reminding me it's such a
fantastic
app I love it I use it on my all my
browsers so you guys did true use this
too do you guys all use it yeah I have
it installed on all my browsers as well
I gotta tell you if you don't have it
okay yeah I gotta tell Joanne because
you you buy stuff online right Jimmy
yeah who does the officers do like
Staples oh Staples
they got coupons and [__] okay so it's
called honey okay honey PayPal but
Honey's the Honey's fine okay yeah also
interesting it doesn't just work on
desktops anymore it works on your iPhone
too just activate it on Safari on your
phone and save on the go
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this show thank you
guys get PayPal honey for free at
joinhoney.com H3 that's joinhoney.com H3
that might be the best read we've ever
done thanks to Jimmy
thank you that was nicely Ethan you look
you're becoming like look we have a kind
of a Frenemies thing going on here too
no I I don't I don't have a close
relationship with my brother for a lot
of reasons you're almost becoming like
my my brother from another mother you're
like a good person that's interesting
Robert Ray I have to say something
um I met him the other days to play a
surgeon and he said something very nice
I'm going back to the story I cut you
off on yeah but it proves the point
about you he said to me you're like a
very happy kind nice person and he gave
me a self and he wants to like have
dinner and hang out I met him for 10
minutes you guys are contemporaries you
know right but the thing is it's like
with you like I'm older if you're nice I
want to hang out with you or not I don't
it doesn't matter whether you have money
or not I have money it's not about that
what's your net worth I asked you that
already didn't I I can't anytime it's
good many times many times yeah but the
thing the thing is I'm older apparently
and you're younger and and it's
important for me to have nice
relationships because I maybe didn't
have would you consider yourself rich
I would say well off not a better word
well Lynn's Rich
yeah yeah I feel that by the way soft so
who's I want to hear wait you want to
hear the joke no no it's not a joke you
want to hear the saying with with me and
Lynn I say can I am I not a curse yes
okay but I'm telling you it's not a joke
it's not a joke okay I'm gonna judge
that Independence it's funny I say you
can't attempt to be funny
no it's funny but I'm gonna type it's
not a joke man I just said you can't
even attack truth but the rules are not
only yeah right like you can't attempt
to be funny I won't I mean it wasn't a
joke you want a green light yeah if it's
just an anecdote that's slightly
humorous that's not really the same as
like being a jokester get an X for it
I'd rather not he can be witty go ahead
go ahead so I always kid with Lynn I go
Lynn I have [__] you money but you have
[__] everybody buddy so it's like cute
but but that's true which makes it funny
it's funny and true
yeah it's funny but then it's not like a
joke it's just you did get a rim shot
though what's a rim shot go ahead Zach
you don't know what a rim shot is and
you're old-timey what what does that
mean after a joke
it's a rim shot yeah oh okay
I didn't know that I I know what that is
I didn't know you called it that okay
all right so who's a apparently a friend
a fan of the show and now a permanent
friend of the show she just randomly
tweeted this out or a story this she
said this is so random but not what I
would usually post but I ordered some
free samples of game or something the
issue podcast had to pay a few quid for
delivery I guess because she's in
England I don't know
uh likely because I I saw some people
saying that they had to pay for shipping
but other people were saying I'm
domestic yeah I think it was outside the
US you might have to pay which is I
think Fair because it's really expensive
very expensive to ship to the public day
anyway she said this mango one tastes so
good honestly thought it would taste too
artificial but to me it tastes like
mango juice so
Sofie I we love you
that's my favorite tune
mango meter what does that say mango
meter that said down at the bottom there
the main the flavor yeah it stiff all
different flavors all different
as our guest uh connected Dan uh they
are okay I'm just gonna I'm sorry to put
you on hold dude I just need to use the
restroom uh before we get into this so
because I don't want to step away you
want to message him that when you're
going to the bathroom to uh no he's
probably watching
uh okay yeah right
yeah I mean you could type to him right
he's on Zoom say hey not before I let
him in okay so anyway we'll be back in
one minute and Jimmy
how am I doing
are you doing phenomenal oh thanks yeah
pound it for that okay I'll be right
back you guys Jimmy talk about um
how when you lost your virginity
I remember the day
who's going to question me on this AB
December 7th 1945. sure it was when I
was uh 15 or 16. mm-hmm
years old was it summer time when it was
the summer time it was a girl because I
grew up at a seashore Town it was a girl
that I met in the summer
I even remember the name of the girl
what's her name
should I say that or live on the air
I do remember her name her first name
what's their first name Amy okay I think
that's generic enough that nobody's
going to be able to yeah she's still
around
I have no idea she came from she had a
summer home there with her mom in
Margate I grew up in Longport a small
little town and uh met her on the beach
the 40s were a wild time dude
it was the 80s get get get get real now
don't push me up higher than I am I
already feel bad enough that I'm in my
50s early 50s so don't make it worse
thanks Olivia you're getting Olivia
loves me
we are younger Jimmy oh I appreciate
that I appreciate you guys having me on
and I appreciate you guys being nice my
goal today is to make friends with Dan
[Music]
Jimmy Jimmy came in today and he gave us
all nicknames do you want to tell
everyone the nickname you gave to Dan
Dan's nickname is is Stalin
can I tell him Zach your nickname please
do king Jew
clever
ab's nickname
yes no yeah yeah
Olivia's nickname bright eyes because
she has beautiful eyes oh see he knows
what he's doing today Sam's nickname is
the hippy Tippy weatherman the airport
the weather is
dark tonight with scattered sunlight
tomorrow she's the hippie dippy weather
girl
and cam is Peter Pan
and what was he in oh he was Harry
Houdini yeah is that that's that's what
my mom used to call me Graham she says
you never want to grow up you always
want to be a kid so Cam's so artistic
and talented he's like a little kid he's
a little kid yeah
do you see your your young self and cam
do you you know you kind of feel a
kinship there
between you between you and cam do you
feel like I think cam is a very kind
nice person oh yeah I just that's the
vibe I haven't came he is and that is
super just a good guy that was how I
felt when I was here this year and he's
like I'm gonna do the edit I said I'm
going to give you some money because I
don't want any money I just I just like
you I said well you don't know me but he
was just so nice to me and we're going
back to the plastic surgeon no cam oh
he's okay I'm gonna eat when he's just
nice Peter Pan Peter Pan all right Les
we have someone on hold yep we have an
esteemed guest here who I'm very much
looking forward to talking to again
let's just get him on the line and then
I'll let him in right now
standby there we go
hey
Sebastian how's it going thanks how's it
going yeah go ahead
oh you got to get that Lacroix cute up
huh get it in the chamber as they say
first of all yes sir thank you so much
for calling in you know I really
appreciate it
you know
so um yeah yeah we're here before we
start because I I just send you guys a
request to uh record it if you guys can
absolutely absolutely
I just clicked allow it doesn't seem so
but that's okay
recording in progress oh wow they really
they really uh let the people know
okay well so where are you at Ethan are
you in the Amazon rainforest
oh you see the green screen no I'm just
in I'm in Los Angeles it looks like a
[__] in actuality but uh here it's
beautiful okay so so Sebastian
um
I kind of was refreshing everybody you
went viral for your Lamborghini clip
and uh a few other things but recently
what caught my attention was this clip
of you talking about me and I thought
let's just go through it let's just go
through it and talk it out right because
that's the best that's the best way to
deal with these things right so let's
hash it out so so here's Sebastian on
Ethan Klein on his Tick Tock page let's
see some people are really stupid Ethan
Klein is the worst okay so I'm I am
really stupid
let's start there I guess
did I say that did I say Ethan Klein is
really stupid oh here I'll go back it's
looking for really stupid Ethan Klein is
more no he said Ethan Kleins
I think some people are really stupid
and then I started when I said that I
was just like okay I gotta talk about
Ethan Klein now what now what made you
think about me when you said I some
people are really stupid because that's
how usually uh in language you're you're
presupposing you say some people are
really stupid like Ethan Klein who I'm
now going to talk about
yeah so I was talking about someone else
uh his name is Bryce Hall and uh we were
just talking about some people basically
jumping to conclusions taking things
that I've said out of context and then
jumping to a conclusion with absolutely
no evidence do you think and then
believing those things well hold on hold
on and then believing those things
without any actual evidence and I was
like okay people like that that don't
dig deep or fully know what they're
talking about are in that moment really
stupid maybe not stupid as people but
just being stupid in the moment okay
interesting we'll put a pin in that
that's interesting so would you say that
this is taken out of context or how what
how would you describe this you say some
people are really stupid Ethan Klein
it's edited like you can't deny that
it's edited to say I'm really stupid
well I didn't I didn't tell the editors
to do it that way they just stay at it
okay I have no I didn't even okay
approve that click before it went out
okay it's on your Tick Tock this is your
official Tick Tock page right official
it says official official no actually
it's not it's so I don't even have the
login to that account I just I have a
team of people that post content for me
to try to get more awareness for like me
um your team is posting on this
correct yeah yes so that's your people
all right so so the stupid thing uh
we're not standing by that which is oh
thank you I appreciate that
I don't think I'm stupid I don't think
I'm the sharpest guy in the world but I
don't I wouldn't say I'm stupid no
you're you're not a no Ethan you're not
a stupid person I mean everybody does
stupid things everybody has stupid
moments mistakes yep I wouldn't say
you're stupid but yeah what you did when
you criticized me you and your wife were
saying some things that were just
complete you were guys were just jumping
to a bunch of conclusions with no
evidence at all and a lot of them are
wrong you guys have this perception of
Me based on like several pieces of
information tiny pieces of information
as to who I am
good great I want to get into all that
so let's go let's just want to take once
we get through this then we can go talk
about whatever we've said
uh here it is we're really stupid Ethan
Klein is the worst person oh we all know
okay so you so you say Ethan Klein's the
worst person on the planet
yes
yes okay so you think I'm the worst
person on the planet I'm quoting you I'm
quoting you actually
I said you're the one who said that I
said you're the worst you've said no you
said you said that I'm the worst no no
you said
I don't know I'm just watching your
video bro
all right listen I'll I'll send your
I'll email or I'll uh DM you a link of
the video where you say I'm the worst
person on the planet you say it I'm
quoting it okay
okay do you remember I don't I don't
remember it to be frank but we can look
it up we can we can look it up
and to be completely honest and I'm sure
you're aware of this
um you don't have like exactly the the
best reputation in the YouTube space
like great your content your content a
lot of the time is is pretty hateful and
pretty negative right I know you guys
have beef with a lot of people you don't
like a lot of people and I know you
don't have the best reputation
um so when you say I don't have the best
reputation do you just mean that I
I am hate I cause a lot of beef is that
what you mean that by reputation well no
because your your content just since the
beginning your content has always been
about like criticizing making fun of
talking [__] disagreeing with people
that have different beliefs than you
making fun of them calling them names
Etc so you have a very negative audience
like a very negative type of content
that you put out there and I know you've
had some beef with some people I know I
just I was doing some research on you
and you had beef with keemstar and
obviously you don't like Andrew Tate and
you I don't know there's probably more
people that you like those two guys
um I don't know anything about keemstar
I've met Andrew before in London um when
I met him he was very nice to me yeah
and he was very nice about Andrew okay
so do you think it's possible that when
I'm criticizing people it's from a place
of like I think maybe the people that
I'm criticizing are doing harm on other
people
yeah I mean sure you can that's fine
like if you think somebody is hurting
someone else and you want to call that
out you can but your style and you can't
you can't even talk
Jimmy uh passed me a note he thinks
you're too young to understand
he says you're a kid has anything to do
with it yeah no no no no no no no no no
just because I'm young doesn't mean I
don't have a lot of wisdom Jimmy I don't
know how old you are but I've been
through a lot in my life I've had a lot
of experiences that people how old are
you how old are you it doesn't matter
that's my entire point is that it does
not matter and I'll tell you I'm 24
years old but I've done a lot of things
and I've been in a lot of positions that
most people haven't and that gives me
experience and wisdom but okay I'm sorry
listen I just wanna let's go through
this video so do you you said this is
the worst person it's just weird if it's
like a joke and you're trying to
reference stuff it's edited like you're
just saying these things you say he's
dumb and he's the worst person in the
world
so are you not take are you gonna
you're not backing that up you're saying
we don't know
Ethan Ethan I'm first of all I'm quoting
you okay second okay so do you believe
I'm the worst person in the world
hold on in this video you say Ethan's
the worst person in the world there's no
context about you making a joke
can I can I answer I just want to stay
on the point yeah of course please
okay
in that video
I'm obviously being sarcastic okay
you're not the worst person on the
planet
all right can you do you understand that
you're smart right I'm obviously being
sarcastic just how I was being sarcastic
when I said everyone in their 20s should
have a Lambo there's sarcasm it's
actually a specific style of sarcasm
called deadpanning or it's designed to
look like I'm almost being realistic
you're doing dead humor
are you the best person no are you a
person that's good are you a net
positive probably not probably not based
on the content that you put out there
that's what I'm saying okay I like that
I like that that's a good starting point
we'll come back to that I'll keep going
we all know this he's the worst person
on the planet he wishes he was us
so this is awesome like um obviously
it's not you saying it but you didn't
challenge him do you think that I wish I
was you or your buddy here
you can be honest no I don't think so I
think that you probably are okay with
who you are
because you're okay okay so your buddy
says
I wish I was him do you think he really
means that because you do a podcast I
don't know
yeah you know uh yeah he's actually my
business partner but yeah I talked to
him
okay I don't know do you wish you were
us
uh absolutely man you guys got it all
I mean everything that I don't know
right like everything I don't have
so you do yeah I was like for example
what is it that you guys have that you
think I would wish to have
well
well I don't I don't believe this but if
you want to talk about this we can talk
about it
um is that what you want to do I'm
curious yeah since it you seem to be
open to entertaining the idea so I'm
curious what are the enviable traits of
your life
do you want to talk about this or can we
can we get through the video I mean I
can tell you this I feel like we're just
like we're okay ranting like we're just
going off okay yeah let's do that I
would love to speak to him I'd love to
talk to him and go on the podcast I
would try to change his life I don't I
think I'd have a hard time be my that'd
be the final boss of this battle some
people are released okay
yeah
go ahead I'm actually really excited to
talk to you yeah I'm really really
excited
I'm all Smiley go ahead man this is your
opportunity
to so yeah change my life
and I'm in desperate
that's the goal man so can I ask you
this and so now that we're done with the
video
why you've you've defended obesity and
you've bragged about being out of shape
and being overweight why do you do that
why don't you think that it's
appropriate to take care of yourself
okay a healthy body thank you for asking
that because you I think it's
interesting you started this
conversation by accusing me and my wife
of taking things out of context and how
bad and how stupid that makes you look
it's funny that you say that because
it's pretty obvious if you go back to
anything I said about it is that I 100
respect people that exercise I obviously
I'm a rational person I understand that
exercise is important it's healthy
um and uh I don't think that obesity is
anything to be brag about in fact I'm
I'm always trying to lose weight people
know it's a big part of my personality
is that I recently gained weight from
taking antidepressants and I'm trying to
work it off and stuff so um and also I
will I will say as a comedian I felt
that to me it was pretty obviously a
joke once again I don't know if I will
call it dead panel have to look up the
exact genre of Comedy maybe you guys
could think about that maybe to help you
consume it
but the point the joke I was making uh
is that
if I spend x amount of time on the
treadmill right
will it make me live x amount of time
more and in the segment we did we
crunched the numbers and we figured out
that um
that uh working out does pay off and in
fact there there's people laughing in
the clip behind that so you started off
by saying that people don't get the
proper contacts so go and so now what
now that you've heard the full context
what are your thoughts about that
well yeah I mean thank you for
explaining it to me that that's a much
better response that's a much better
stance on it I would right that was
always my agree with you yeah well
that's good yeah that's good well thank
you for explaining it to me yeah it's
good I would say you should try very
hard to exercise and have a great body
it makes you feel good if you feel good
you're gonna think good you're gonna
perform better you're gonna be happier
about yourself you're gonna be proud of
yourself it's good for your mental
health it increases no I agree so yeah
so that's great I mean that's great I
are you still on antidepressants yes I
am
so you're you're currently would you
describe yourself as a depressed person
are you currently depressed uh no I'm
not currently depressed
can I eat you why are you taking
well yeah because um
yeah I was depressed I was having a hard
time a few years ago and you know I
decided to uh try Lexapro and it's
really helped me a lot it's actually
um I recommend people that are feeling
depressed that they should actually they
should I think people should try it in
fact I recommend it
so I would disagree I would say that
there's a lot of things you could try
before taking medication synthetic
medication to cure this because
depression can come from a lot of things
and if you sit down and think about it
um it's probably going to be different
for every single person but I was
depressed at one point my mom was
depressed we were depressed for
different reasons my mom took
antidepressants I didn't I was depressed
because I didn't like the way that I
looked when I was a kid and instead of
taking medication I just tried really
hard to get really so when you say that
you have the wisdom hold on well you
well hold on this is important you
acknowledge that you've been depressed
but you also talk about you have the
wisdom of 24 year old do you think that
there's other reasons that people could
be depressed other than kind of
adolescence anxiety about the way that
they look which is pretty common let's
be real I think everybody's uh insecure
yeah yeah absolutely I think there's
there's a there's several reasons why
people could be depressed and I'm not
gonna try to name them off to you but I
think that there's plenty of reasons
people could be depressed but either way
depression will come from not you're not
in a situation that you like you're not
where you like to be whether that's done
to you outside of you or whether you've
done it to yourself it's just you're not
happy with your situation or where
you're at in life and a lot of the a lot
of the times you can personally make a
change or you can react differently to
make that situation better and and doing
that like actually reacting like for me
to go to the to the gym and come up with
a diet plan and learn and work on
getting a six-pack back is a lot harder
than popping popping pills is the easy
way out
right so yeah you know what's
interesting so it's like everyone's
gonna always opt for not everyone but
they're most of the time you're going to
opt for the easiest route but I don't
believe that the easiest route is the
good route I think it's a harder route I
actually think your opinion is super
toxic and it's actually super basic and
you talk about wisdom no and I'll
explain to you why well you're making a
lot of assumptions about me again I've
been to a lot of therapy and I've tried
lots of things to improve my situation
the pills was the last the last
this ditch effort
to do something to help my situation in
fact if you'll know I had the pills next
to my bed for months because I was so
apprehensive to take it because of all
the opinions of people like you who and
because I felt that too like that it's
the and uh people say it's the easy way
out people who kind of are in the sigma
grind set like you is actually the
hardest decision I had to make in my
mental health recovery was the decision
to take the pill right and I think for a
lot of people that's the real the
reality of taking antidepressants is not
the easy way out it's actually the
hardest decision to make my mom went
through it and what you said's right
what you just said is right she went
through this for years right she was
bipolar so
you said the truth you spoke from your
heart thank you Jimmy you're making me
almost
crying that's crazy well it's it's toxic
because
I've heard this opinion a lot of your
peers and people who share that opinion
with you and I think it's toxic because
it's discouraging men specifically from
seeking out valid and very helpful
treatments for their problems you think
that going to the gym is going to
resolve all your issues and I think
that's actually no you talk about it I
didn't say that but you say I said look
if you don't like if you don't like the
way you look get in the gym don't take
an antidepressant pill that that is not
a talk I could have told you that and
that is the correct thing that is the
correct thing to do yeah but that's not
that interesting of a statement is it
because that's it doesn't have to be
interesting yeah oftentimes the correct
thing is boring and it's it's yeah sure
it could be basic I also don't think
that's clinical depression uh you have
24 years of wisdom so I don't want to uh
I don't want to patronize you but if
you're able to go to the gym and go
through the depressed and get kind of
shake off the depression I don't think
that is clinical depression that's not
depression yeah that's experience yeah I
mean who are you to say why I I felt
depressed I had a very depressive
feeling well there is a clinical part
about myself yeah there is a clinic I
mean you it's an opinion no it's not you
guys can't you're not you have no
authority to say what is what what's
okay to cause my depression or what
isn't I mean I don't know why you're
depressed but I'm not going to sit here
and say well that's not a fair reason to
be depressed why are you depressed why
were you depressed no no I'm not saying
it's not a fair reason I'm saying that
there is a clinical definition of what
clinical depression is right and chances
are if you're young and you go to the
gym and Shake It Off You probably don't
have clinical depression and can I ask
you were you ever diagnosed with
depression
yeah I think I went to uh when I went
and got therapy for a period of time and
I went to a psychiatrist as well and
they said I like I just have some some
similar symptoms like I'm over there but
you're over I didn't take any medication
any medication for it I worked my way
out of it and this is this is also can I
say so you say you worked your way out
of it it implies that people who have
clinical depression are not doing
everything that they can to get rid of
it before they take the medicine there's
this implicit
thing that you and your peers say is
that people who have depression are weak
and that if they taking the medicine
that's a sign of weakness right you're
seeing no not at all medicine is a
pop-out it's the easy way out
no no no not at all I'm not saying
people that have depression are weak I'm
I'm I would argue that most people feel
depressed at some point in their life
that's what I that's what I would feel
most people that's not an argument
that's that's a known fact people go
through the personal periods it's
absolutely normal
right so everyone has been there and
it's not weak for you to be depressed
everyone has been depressed no that's
not maybe in that moment
that's maybe in that moment you're being
a little bit weak in that moment is the
weakness that you're implying
I'm saying that there's a lot that
should be done before you take medicine
and I'm also saying that even though
you're not I'm saying that is going to
be hard like whatever that you have to
do before you take medicine whether it
be go to the gym or work and mend a
relationship it's going to be extremely
difficult and people are going to give
up far too soon for it it fixes itself
and they can pull themselves out of that
feeling out of that state okay so taking
a pill yes you said you could you could
think about taking it for months and it
can be on your mind but if you for you
to go into the gym or for you to fix
something in your life that could take
way longer than months and it can be way
harder than thinking about taking a pill
do you think and people oftentimes give
up you got you and you and your uh
contemporaries talk often about going to
the gym it's very important to you guys
and it seems almost like and I I Bradley
Martin's a friend of mine and I don't
mean to otherwise my kids are in the gym
all the time so it's good kids his age
they're all kudos to him like my son's
one be built they lift weights they want
to look good for the girls they made
some good food the gym that's a good
thing my kids do it there's this weird
emphasis that like the gym can fix all
your problems and I find that all
right no not at all I'm not saying that
at all I'm just saying this this will
fix one of the problems and and
absolutely all men should go to the gym
men should be proud of who what they
look like men should be strong that's
their job you have to protect your girl
your girlfriend your wife you have to
protect your kids so it's your job as a
man to be physically strong to protect
those people that rely on you okay for
sure so your job as a man is to be
strong to protect them from physical
violence if you need to one of one of
the many jobs yes one of the many jobs
you have one of the many
responsibilities of being a man right
and in the modern world I understand
that because uh as we all know there's
constantly Bandits and uh Vigilantes and
barbarians uh coming at us with spiked
maces and [__]
Ethan if somebody were to break into
your house
and you are not protected from it and
you were let's say you fight up against
this dude and this dude has more he's
stronger than you and he has more
training of combat experience than you
he's going to kill you he's going to win
yeah he's going to do whatever he wants
to do to your wife and your kids and
break your house and that's just it's
just it's a hype well I have a gun
because a fool would only a fool would
try to engage them in combat yeah I have
a shotgun from defense it'd be foolish
what if you can't load your gun in time
what if you can't get to your gun in
time what if he has a gun well why would
a situation yeah if someone broke up
without a weapon right you're just not
as prepared to deal with any situation
possible and that that's just something
that I don't feel good about like I
would rather be more prepared and better
safe than sorry
also would make me feel more confident I
wouldn't I wouldn't like have more
anxiety I wouldn't have more worry in my
bed at night if somebody were to break
in or it can't hurt Sound Outside let me
ask you I would feel better about myself
can a six-pack stop bullets
I mean if if you work it out hard enough
maybe I don't know right
because it just seems like I mean being
strong looks cool
and some women like it yeah well I don't
I don't just work out either Ethan I
also do like I train Muay Thai and Jiu
Jitsu I do Combat Sports I go to the gym
I do cardio I do all sorts of stuff I do
a lot of things I go rock climbing I go
rock climbing I play tennis yeah that
sounds super fun it can be that sounds
super fun and cool
it is it's better than making fun of
people on the internet all day oh that
was below the belt
that was below the belt that last
comment below it's okay this we're here
to talk everything out well that's
you're talking about my professional you
should come with me you should come with
me you can we can go together
the world you need to learn we can fight
25 years it would it would inspire you
you'd be like this is fun let's do it
more so let me ask you this some men are
smaller in Statue uh or they just doomed
to be a pathetic partner because they
can't protect their family what's your
thoughts on small statured small muscled
people who love you you know what I mean
the little guy the little guy no yeah
yeah my business partner is is average
or a little bit below average height
and they should do hold on and they
should do they should do just that they
should also prepare and train themselves
when I was in Jiu Jitsu there was plenty
of people that were smaller than me when
I started out that had more experience
than me that would kill me I want to ask
you I want to ask you a very specific
question though
protecting the family is part of a man's
job
so if you take
a really short guy like five foot
he's gonna be better at that job or
you're going to be way better at that
job than him just on paper right you are
better if when it comes to protecting
the family you got that on the little
guy
you could speak I understand what your
point is no the point is that you as a
man have a job to protect the family
your some people are better at
protecting the family because they're
stronger and bigger and some people are
worse at protecting the family because
they're SM they're littler or fatter or
less muscular so if a woman had to
really no hold on let me let me answer I
want to get the logic out of you if okay
if I want to answer yes yeah okay okay
go ahead so are you better at protecting
your family than a five-foot dude
no I think like I just said it depends
on your level of of competence it
depends on how well trained you are so
you think a five foot dude
you okay look if you interrupt me all
the time I'm never gonna you're never
gonna understand what I'm trying to say
you're asking me a question
no you're right they're gonna sit for
gold dude go ahead
it depends on your level of training if
there is a five foot guy that came into
my house and he is the most badass
military dude that's been training for
years he will he'll probably win right I
don't have as much I think there's a
five foot guy there's a [__] Navy
SEAL
I probably absolutely
um I think it depends on your level of
competence like I just said when I was
doing Jiu Jitsu there are people that
were smaller than me that would win that
would win against me on a ground fight
because they're way more trained in Jiu
Jitsu and same goes from Muay Thai there
could be a guy that's a little bit
shorter than me or has like a smaller
reach than me and he could beat me in
muay thai if he's been training his
entire life because he has a better
strategy than I do now if you were to
take somebody that smaller and me and we
have the same exact level of training
then odds are I would probably win
because I'm just bigger and I have more
strength yes obviously there's that's
not a surprise but I but I'm not saying
that if you're little you have no chance
at all if you're little you just have
less extra work to do you have more work
to do yeah
why how tall are you Ethan I mean you're
pretty tall aren't you all right well
yeah I'm like I'm like 5 11 but it
doesn't matter really because I have a
gun you have a gun yeah yeah you have a
garden so you're fine yeah right exactly
but exercising's cool hey so let's move
on to something else
um this tweet we talked about on the
show you said you should be able to see
it on your computer men literally want
one thing large mountain style home in
the forest by Lake Pleasant wife with no
attitude three to five kids
well specifically what is a pleasant
wife with no attitude can you give me
can you give me another record thank you
what's a pleasure you guys you guys for
five minutes you were like thank you he
literally said
men want one thing and he lists it off
five things and in that moment I
realized that like any time you were
looking into me anytime that you got
into something that was actually
interesting you're like okay parents
grew up poor came from a communist
country mom grew up uneducated somehow
this kid's a millionaire boring okay
degeneration
sales for his clients he made a bunch of
money on the internet boring and then I
go to this and you have you guys talk
about well let's well why well I'm here
to talk about interesting stuff I'm not
here to happen here to talk [__] Yeah
well yeah well no I'm here I want to
and I think what's important what's
interesting is that we talk about the
places where we conflict and I think
it's great that you're an immigrant and
you came to America and succeeded it's
like oh okay great what do you want me
to do suck your dick Ethan no is it not
more interesting that my parents came
here to escape communism they could
barely speak the language and I lifted
my that's awesome and turned us into
multi-millionaires is that much more
interesting than me saying men want one
thing yes but it's uncontroversial why
would I want to discuss that tell me
what is a pleasant wife with no attitude
Sebastian can I ask you know what an
interesting conversation is do you think
an interesting conversation until
someone just sucking your dick and doing
a puff piece I think that is what you
think it is based on your podcast no not
at all not at all I've done it I've done
interesting stuff and we could have
interesting tell me you wrote it what is
a pleasant wife with no attitude
I'm just saying Ethan that there is a
lot of interesting conversations that
don't have to be controversial but you
don't know that because your entire
brand is based on content no no I'm
having a interesting conversation what's
his job based on our differences of
opinion
do you want a wife with Attitude what
does attitude mean
a wife that nags a wife that talks back
to you a wife that remarks at you and
and says sly comments do you want that
in your house right well do you think
that when a woman quote unquote nags
that that's just like an inherent
quality of of women because you act like
it's kind of right because you act like
there would never be a reason for a
woman to bother you about anything like
your significant other would never have
a legitimate reason to quote nag you
I would never want my wife to call me
weird names or like make remarks towards
me yeah like I would never want her to
say that I'm stupid or I don't look good
or or just of course well that's just me
if I ask her to do something I wouldn't
I wouldn't I wouldn't want her to to
have an attitude with me and to yeah I
would want her to act and and speak to
me as if we're on the same team the same
way that I would do that for her yeah
but that's just that's obvious you're
you you're saying I don't want her to
call me ugly I mean that's just mean
that's just like a toxic relationship
that's nothing to do with Pleasant wife
with no attitude
sometimes sometimes an attitude is
warranted right like you got a little
attitude with me today
and that's cool right because because
that's that's that's warranted because
it's a little bit contentious our
conversation so sometimes an attitude is
uh is Justified right
I don't know it depends on the scenario
okay okay and so it depends on the
scenario so is there ever a scenario
that you would have with your
significant other that would warrant her
to have an attitude with you
I mean yeah I imagine if I like did
something really stupid like if I I
don't know I would never do this because
I'm not a cheater but I could imagine if
I cheated she'd have an attitude which
is I think that's a mile and putting it
mildly yeah I would never do that
because that is not not the person that
I am but yeah I just want a pleasant
wife with no attitude I don't think
there's anything wrong with that I would
say that I would say that most women
would want a pleasant husband that has
ambition and has goals and I think
that's fine well well yeah and I want
that in my woman too I want a smart
woman who has Ambitions and goals too
but we're also you agree with me you
agree with me on one thing well no I I
think that people want partners that
they respect
so you you agree with me but you just
don't like my verbiage no I think you're
you're at your verbage of no attitude
implies that women are docile creatures
there to be subservient and just obey
and to you know they're just they're
they're making your home right that's
just an assumption that's just an
assumption but it's in delay I love
women women are the I didn't say you
don't love them
I know but they have a role to play they
have a role right no they're the most
yeah well women and men have a role to
play of course
right but they have a specific what is
the woman's role
it's not subservient they don't have to
be subservient to the man but they they
complement the man and a man compliments
a woman they make a great team together
okay you're not saying anything what is
the woman's role
to be what do you mean the woman's role
in a household yeah can you in a
relationship and a household yeah
oh let's see
you know I find it interesting that
you're being so thoughtful about it now
because I've seen millions of videos of
you spitting this [__] off like this is
what a woman needs to do they need to be
at home they need to support the man and
always thoughtful no no I'm always
thoughtful and and those but it seems
like something you would know same thing
okay go ahead
those videos are highly edited but you
put it up on your Tick Tock bro it's
your [__] voice it's your it's your
team you pay people to put it on the
internet to make you look cool to other
dudes that's why it's there let me let
me answer your question please let me
let me just think about it so I give you
a good answer you said women prefer to
submit
why is that funny yeah I think that's
true um okay now we're getting some I
think I think a girls I think a girl's
job
I think a girl's job is to display a lot
of love and a lot of hold on let me get
in Focus yes focus
I think a girl's job is to be
the affectionate one to be extremely
affectionate and to be very loving you
sound in sufficient and very and very
understanding in for their children and
their and their husbands
and
to make the children feel loved and hurt
I think that's a woman's job I think
it's her job to women women have this
this kind of love for their children
that nobody else in the world wonders
no I love see that's a little crazy to
me
I'm sure you do but I think that you
think my wife loves my kids and more
than me or differently no I never said
that no I said that they're different I
I think a father and a mother will love
their children differently not more than
the other but just in different ways
um that's crazy okay that's fine
um and a father is going to want to
protect his kids and he's going to want
to provide an environment where his
family can feel safe and he's also going
to work muscular like that's that's not
really an active role in there lessons
Okay wisdom to his his children like the
medieval mother is
no this is just nature
wisdom like of what are we doing sitting
around a campfire singing songs and [__]
I feel like you're Ethan you're all
right you're almost 40 40 years old I'm
34 years old yeah these things that
you're saying like you're just snapping
back at me nothing you're saying it's
not like you're not disproving me in any
way you're just saying whatever comes
through my channel opinions
you're being very yeah but we're not
even having a conversation I'm just
talking and you're just like spitballing
off everything that I say well like
trying to correct me like like a little
kid it's just a very childish well
you're you're going off into places I
know I'm not gonna there are not a good
topic because you're you're gonna go on
and explain things that are pretty
obvious and uncontroversial like you go
I just want women to be like nice to me
I mean
you said women prefer literally what I
said I want women to be women prefer I
want women you you took that however you
took it I said I want women to be
pleasant with no attitude that means if
hey if I don't want you to do something
because it makes me feel whatever
uncomfortable then please don't like
make it a huge deal that's yeah thank
you I think you're okay what so you
think women prefer to submit this is
something you've said okay so we're just
we're gonna ignore everything well what
do you want if you want to go have a
specific conversation I want you to stop
acting I want you to stop acting like a
child I want you to let me speak and
then we can discuss
women prefer to submit is that correct
I think women are happier
when when they feel like their husbands
can properly leave them or their meds I
think women are happier when they know
that the person that they're with is
going to make the right decision and
they don't have to worry about it and I
would say that's a form of submission in
a way yes
I would agree
just what I've seen in myself 24 years
how many how many long-term
relationships have you been in
I've been in a few long-term
relationships I'm not going to tell you
the number because I mean you've only
been legally allowed to even have sex
for six years so
well in my culture we don't we don't
have to have we don't necessarily have
sex
I don't know I'm Christian and Romanian
so like we don't just date and then hook
up on the first night that's not how it
works okay
okay so in your experience women like to
be uh uh uh most most women would agree
with that women would agree with do you
talk to a lot of women
um when I'm single yes but most women
would agree with that and they do
they're like they want a man that's like
hey if if my guy's gonna it always makes
the right decision I'd prefer to just
let him do his thing well I don't want
to see them I'm sure your wife is like
that too Ethan I'm sure I don't know
what's your wife's name could you tell
me Ela
Gila yeah
yeah I'm sure she's like that too and
that's a form of submission
I don't want to be presumptuous but
there are women here do you guys want to
talk about do you are you happier
submitting
I also like it when my partner is nice I
also like it when
um my partner doesn't say I'm ugly I
also like it when my partner
um is nice to kids and animals I like
that
um
I like a partner who likes my strength
I think what's your name I'm Olivia can
you tell me your name so Olivia my
question was
do you like it when you're a man say you
have I don't know if you have a
boyfriend or husband or whatever but
theoretically when you're mad if you
were to always make the right decision
and you felt inside of you that you
could trust him and you didn't have to
worry would you prefer that to the
alternative which is I don't think that
my man is making the right decision
right now and I'm gonna have to figure
this out on his behalf which which would
you prefer
and you can be honest
I would prefer that both of us exactly
know how to do it together like that's
what I do I would rather have a say than
not have a say talk but you're implying
it's a mass it's a it's a masculine
trait to be dependable and it's not a
one a female trait to be Dependable you
see what look you're not explicitly
saying that but you're asking you're
like you women want a man that could
depend on it's not as important for men
though because it's not really a
feminine trait for a woman to be
dependable
no women have to be Dependable but okay
so what's the difference probably
they're just Dependable they're just
Dependable opinion I would imagine an
opinion I for one don't think that the
whole submitting thing is right I prefer
a partnership if you were paying Asian
it's more that's Lena by the way she's a
woman
okay so you guys you you ladies prefer
partnership that's fine then just
imagine a scenario where you're you're
with a husband and for every single
decision that he has to make he's going
to come and consult you for every single
thing he's hey babe what do you think
about this like he has no sense of
leadership or direction if it concerns
both of us you really want that if it's
something that's just in his life
important he can handle himself but if
it concerns me I'd like to know about it
I'd like to get my input on it I think
it's actually fascinating that you bring
that up like why would you want your man
to consult you because he because he
thinks you're an equal and values your
opinion on things I mean if I I mean are
you saying oh I don't want to ask my
wife what gum I should chew right now or
like what are you talking about because
it's obvious that in big life decisions
you should consult your partner
look my girlfriend
she trusts me if I say it's a better
decision for us to financially do this
or to wait until we do this right um I
will tell her I'll explain it to her and
she'll give me suggestions sometimes
she'll trust me sometimes and not give
me suggestions I'll be open with her and
if she does give me a suggestion I'm not
just going to toss it in the trash no
I'm going to listen to her and honor her
um I don't think that we are really
disagreeing on much here I think that
we're literally just I think
right but okay so then what's
interesting is that
you are appealing
to this red pilled Community this is if
you go to your Tick Tock if you go to
your YouTube this is your identity
you're getting these men and you're
telling them that this is the alpha way
of life and when you say that we're not
that different I do agree uh and we kind
of both understand which is the obvious
what makes a good relationship and stuff
but the way you paint it online is you
say women are submissive and then what
you just said is like when you have to
make a financial decision it's your
decision right but you'll ask but uh you
know you'll take but she's she's in no
position to make that decision right
that's ultimately your decision
that's you I don't think that we're that
similar I think that we're just agreeing
about this specific thing
um just to correct you there and then I
don't know what you asked me well you're
presenting your opinion in a way that I
think is harmful to Men to Men
specifically actually because women know
better right and and and I think some
women have a like traditional Ethan yeah
Ethan let me let me just say something
you most of your content most of your
audience used to be men and now it's not
now majority of your audience is women
and my audience looks up to me they're
inspired by me and I've had
conversations with plenty of men
older younger same age that have said
that I've changed their life for the
better they feel happy happier they feel
better about themselves and they're in a
much better position in life right now
because I've inspired them most of my
audience is males so I don't think you
can say that I'm not a good role model
for men when your audience list used to
literally be mostly men okay and over
time men have stopped watching you
because they don't look up to you in any
way you're not a role model to these men
they don't want to consume your content
your content is very hateful it's
uninspiring okay okay my content is very
inspiring so hold on I'm almost done go
ahead go ahead I've been in I've been in
to give you an example I've been in a
car with someone before that he stopped
me and he works for me now but he says
Sebastian my father was never around I
don't have any older brothers I don't
have anyone to look up to you're
literally the only person I've ever
looked up to and I you have made me such
a better person I've gotten in the gym
I've taken care of myself started a
business and now I'm making good money
and this this kid it was 18 was crying
on crying in front of me when I met him
for the first time how many people I was
that much of a role model I've had
people cry when they meet me probably
more than you
yeah but probably not because you
inspired them probably just because why
not and
do you think people just cry because I'm
famous I'm people shed tears for me bro
they're a mess
I don't think that you would even
disagree let me when I say that I'm a
much better role model at 24 for men
than you are at 30. okay good good let's
I'll come back by the way my my audience
is like 50 50 male and female
uh but you're right my it used to be a
majority man but let me go back to what
you said you said because you are a
because a lot of men look up to you
you're more qualified to talk about
what's good for men uh I didn't say that
oh so what was your point
I didn't say that I said I'm a much I
said I'm a better role model for men and
I don't think there's I don't think you
should I don't think you're a role model
for men at all right
because I have a more women audience
because you used to you used to have a
more male audience and now you don't I
am because men have no reason no reason
to look up to you right well a lot of
people looked up the Hitler does that
mean he was right
no of course not but I'm not I'm not
Hitler no I'm not no I'm not crazy it's
a it's an extreme example but just
because you have people that look up to
you it doesn't make you right
I mean yeah that was just a very poor
poor example that doesn't really like
that doesn't prove you're right or
anything so what okay so this this is
good what do you think makes you a
better role model than me
I encourage men to exercise and I lead
by example okay exercise what if I told
you exercise is not the second the most
important the second thing is I
encourage men to become financially
independent and there's plenty of ways
you can do that leveraging the internet
okay you've seen it because you've done
it yourself so you know that I'm right
and there's plenty of ways to do it as
well and I encourage men to do that
instead of the alternative which is
going and getting a job that they might
regret later in life and they do that
okay I also encourage men to not be a
degenerate not sleep around with a bunch
of girls and to get one girl to be loyal
to that girl and to build a family with
her that's what I encourage men to do
okay so those three those three things
are very very important for me among
others as well but those are I would say
like the most important ones
okay and that makes you a better role
modeler than me how
because you don't you don't do that you
don't promote exercise you spread a
bunch of hate you don't love anyone your
whole entire world view is negative
you're like you don't you don't spread
love like what do you mean I don't love
anyone
I meant to say that you don't like you
don't spread love
is extremely negative okay
do you do you think that you disagree
like no I do I do I do I think I think
you can observe that I criticize a lot
of people right but the people I
criticize I think are are very worthy of
being criticized for example Andrew Tate
I think is
is just
doing Untold damage to a whole
generation of men
uh but do you think that there's other
ways to inspire people other than going
to the gym and doing Drop Shipping and
[__] like that
how do you think that you inspire people
Ethan Do you believe you inspire people
I wouldn't presume to do that much you
know what I mean but I do think probably
there's people I wouldn't presume to uh
to even to make that assumption though
you know um Ethan the thing is is you
it's a little bit of hubris isn't it
it's a little bit of Huber you have to
look at yourself as a savior like that
no I don't um I you criticize everyone
it's not really my goal either I'm an
Entertainer except yourself I'm not a
self-help yourself right you're not a
self-help guy I mean I'm an Entertainer
I'm not a self-help Guru
sure yeah I mean not okay anyway let me
show you this we're trying to say this
is going to blow your [__] mind Ethan
inspired me to lose weight I'm under 200
pounds please someone Mayo up their dumb
look at I inspired this man right here
that's a picture Batman he would cry if
he ever met me boy I'll tell you what
tears kisses and hugs man and I'd be
like I love you dude
there's an inspiration right there
that's very inspirational good job you
inspired one person good job so you
think he's the only one out there he
inspired me no I think he told me I
can't do jokes today
do you think making people laugh is uh
do you think making people laugh is
important
I don't think that you make people laugh
I don't think that you're talking okay
come on that's it I mean come on like
you might not think I'm funny but we get
a million views per podcast but one of
the most important we're one of the most
biggest podcasts in the world like you
can't you can't say that I don't make
people laugh oh God like even if you
don't find me funny that's kind of a
crazy thing to say your brand your brand
has been on a downtrend for the last two
years your brand is dying that's not
true is it your Tweet your Tweet got
less likes you got like 300 you tweeted
directly to you dummy it wasn't a public
tweet
it was literally I tweeted directly to
you you understand how Twitter works
right yes okay yeah good I do so then
why would that get a lot of likes
your brand is dying why would that get a
lot of life and it's it's it's going to
continue dying because of the type of
content that you push it's not really
dying though is it there's there's a lot
of yes it is in what way is it dying
unsubscribed for me people have
consistently unsubscribed from your
channel and and so it's so people
unsubscribing this one metrics proves
that my brand is dying
no and the the overall reputation that
you have in the YouTube community and
when I looked up your name to just do
research on who you are because I don't
know who you are there is no shortage of
videos talking about you don't know who
I am you used to be so much more popular
and you used to be funny back in the day
but now you're like this I used to be
the new person that spreads a ton of
hate wait you don't know who I am did
you know who I am when you made that
Tick Tock saying I'm the worst person in
the world and that I'm dumb
I know who you are hold on because you
looked me up after I reached out and it
was after that video it seems that you
made a lot of presumptions about no no I
know I I've known who you are but I've
never like watched or consumed your
content okay I don't know you as a
person you just I don't know you as a
person well yeah I mean I'm quoting you
Sebastian can I pull up your analytics
your shit's on the down curve brother
your career is going down to the [__]
thumbs bro I mean that that is a
colossal dump bro that's off the cliff
and I mean at least mine is like pretty
flat but that is treacherous man you are
going down like the Titanic brother
that is rough
ly hold on
yeah so yeah my analytics are down
because I haven't posted content I
posted a video with my mom that I knew
wouldn't do well and I just posted a
video yesterday so yes I know my
analytics are down I'm taking uh a
little bit of a break from YouTube
because I've been getting a lot of heat
on the internet so I just wanted to take
a step back that's why they're down
tough being out there as a Creator huh I
don't think you're gonna make it you see
if you have thin skin like that I mean
that's why it's going down I think it'll
be fun you'll be fine I think it'll be
fine Ethan if I can interact in his
behalf I think he's going to do better
than all of us together oh thank you
Jimmy not you and me him him yeah
Sebastian yeah but I I I I it's just my
opinion our podcast is always as
continually in the top charts of the
most popular podcasts in the world and
um our viewership is phenomenal I don't
know if what you know is normal
viewerships for a podcast but regularly
getting a million views on a podcast and
we post four or five times a week
that's pretty that's pretty impressive
don't you think
like clearly people like the show
yeah I mean okay
Checkmate yeah
um okay okay cool listen
uh let's see I have other things I want
to talk to you about
um here's one about what girls can't
wear so let's see let's take a look at
this there I think she can and cannot
wear well it depends I mean fashion is
so broad
opposite but if she's dressed
provocatively and I'm not with her
there's absolutely no reason why
there's attention I'm trying to get if
I'm not there if I go out with her
that's another thing you should only
care about my attention if you're my
wife there should be no other attention
from a man that you should care about
other than mine at all except for your
father and your brother that's it so so
your stance is you can look pretty when
you're with me
but if you're not with me you need to
not look pretty
no okay wrong
my stance is you shouldn't dress
provocatively unless you're with me
what's provocative
like showing a ton of cleavage or
wearing as little clothing as possible
okay so it's cool when they're with you
but if they go out looking like that
it's not okay and I mean no I would say
even I even when they're with me I
wouldn't want them to do that in public
okay
what's the problem
well it just it's a little insecure
no it's not it is a little it's a
preference
well in this video because you're kind
of walking it back so we can move on if
you want but in this video you say dress
sexy when you're with me but not when
you're not with me
yeah no I would say now you're saying
don't you ever dress don't dress I'm not
saying dress sexy women can dress sexy
and not provocatively you can dress sexy
and be and look Tastefully good without
showing like your tits and your butt and
whatever but it's a breath I would say
it's a preference I don't like it
okay okay that's fair that's fair no
that's fair if you have that
understanding with your partner I think
that's totally fair but this pressure
it's not insecurity either it's it's not
insecurity it's just I don't want I
don't like that it is like let's follow
the thing no it's not because you're
you're basically no it's not you're what
you want would you want your wife out
there okay your wife out there dress
like a hoe
well the definition of a hoe I guess is
I'm not quite sure what that means
but you're just answer my question would
you would you want her out there
dressing or wearing as minimal clothing
as possible out in a club
what I want my well hold on
hold on no answer the question okay well
let me show you this it's a yes or no
okay well hold on is my wife dressed
like a hoe here because I just want to
get your she posted this to so would you
would you go out to dinner with your
wife dressed like that of course you
wouldn't go like that I mean what
I don't know why she's posting I mean
that's that's you and your wife your
relationship
I'm trying to understand your point
would you do you think she's dressed
like a hoe right now and you can say yes
it's fine
yeah I wouldn't want her posting I
wouldn't want my girlfriend posting
pictures because that's a preference
from insecurity right because no it's
not because it's a prep I don't want
that yeah because it makes you feel
insecure
it doesn't make me feel insecure how
does it make her feel secure how does it
make you feel
I don't like the the hold on let's
the how the women is how that girl's
portraying herself like how she's
basically advertising and like saying
like look how nice my body looks for the
entire world to see for the entire
public to see I don't like that I want
why to just save that for me why don't
you like what I like but I don't know
what other people seeing it it's mine
are you not mine it's yours it's yours
it's my wife I don't want everyone to
see she's my wife
yes and I'm hers okay and so
well to me I don't want to control I
want my my wife Ila to be as powerful
and confident as she wants to be I'm not
threatened by other women looking at her
in a way that they think maybe she's
attractive or maybe she looks hot or
whatever because I trust her right she
knows well hold on hold on I know that
there's no one else out there who's
going to tempt her away from me and I
want her to feel powerful and confident
yeah she's with me and nobody's gonna do
anything exactly he's not going to do
anything right and so and so I just I
just want you to dig a little deeper and
explain why you don't like it because
it's yours because she's yours and
nobody else can see my body nobody else
can see her body yeah
even if she wants to show it because she
wants to feel she doesn't want to oh it
doesn't she doesn't want to I know but
you're a role model and you're putting
this out on your Tick Tock this is what
you're putting out I know you guys have
a preference when I'm talking about your
influence on men so if she wants to go
out and dress sexy and look good you're
against that
yes yes
I'm against her dressing provocatively
she can look nice because because for
women putting on makeup and dressing
sexy and going out it makes them feel
powerful makes them feel good it makes
them feel confident it's not necessarily
about what the [__] others you know it's
what it is is what makes them feel
powerful about it is when they go out
and they dress really nice what what
gives them the power is the attention
that they get it doesn't have to be a
guy walking up to them it could be a guy
looking at them and that's what gives
them the power it's the attention from
other men okay and if that weren't true
then they could dress up and look
amazing and just that's true and they
could stay in home or they could look in
the mirror and without anyone around so
they can dress up but stay at home
I don't think that if I have a
girlfriend she should go up she should
have a desire to go out there and even
seek the attention from other men
because the attention she gets from me
is enough to fulfill her all that's what
validation like don't we all crave
validation in some way you should you
should get enough validation from your
wife and your wife should get enough
from you she should be inspired by you
and maybe if she had it maybe if you had
a six-pack she would be more inspired by
you and she wouldn't post thirst traps
on Instagram but you should be inspired
by your significant other okay so me not
having a six pack is is uh promoting my
wife to seek male attention because I'm
not hot enough because my attention is
not working maybe maybe if maybe if you
took care of yourself Ethan and you were
in better shape maybe she wouldn't I
don't I'm not saying that I'm just
saying maybe no it's a good hypothesis
it's a good hypothesis so if I was
hotter maybe not if I was hotter
she saw you if she saw you and you're
like wow he really cares and respects
himself and I like his attention and I
don't need to go out there and look for
attention from guys in the comments or
whatever don't you see you're insecure
because I know she's not insecure yes it
is you are insecure dude
okay you you're threatened by the
attention other attention that people
give to your significant other
I'm not threatened by it at all I I know
that there's not going to be other guys
out there that can compete with me for
my girl my girl I don't even need to
compete
I just don't I'm not even thinking about
it I'm not threatened I'm not threatened
I just don't like it it doesn't threaten
me if she wanted if she wanted look
Ethan if she wanted to post a picture
and I said look I don't I'm not
comfortable I don't like it and she did
it anyway that's fine she can do it
anyway and then we I would just be like
hey this breaks the boundary of the
relationship this breaks the the
sanctity of the intimate relationship I
want to have with my wife right um I'm
gonna just split here I'm gonna go find
a girl that respects me it's not about
insecurity it's just this is my
preference this is how I want to conduct
my life I I like to to take control of
my life and live my life the way I think
that's fine for me but you're putting
and you don't like the messages you
don't want men as a role model
self-proclaimed Role Models yes you
refer to your girlfriend as she's yours
I mean she's a human being right with
their own desires she's not an obvious
absolutely she is mine and I'm hers we
are to Die free don't you feel a little
[__] when you walk around with your
big biceps out and [__]
are you looking for validation from
people in chat
because you're crying I'm just trying to
show you guys I'm just trying to flex on
you but I'll show you guys what's up no
but like you think that it's funny you
think you're being funny but you
actually just totally undermined
everything you said you're putting out
your your biceps why are you doing it
for validation
I'm not doing it for Value you just said
you wanted to show it off you just said
you wanted it was a joke Ethan I just
put on a shirt and I'm okay but okay so
it's a joke but I'm sorry that my my
biceps are big and they're and you're
looking we'll cover up I'm sorry that my
wife has big beautiful titties
I'm gonna
I'm gonna go take a take a piss real
quick can you guys give me one yeah
please yeah please go ahead
I feel Dan more normal now you better
like me now
uh I'm Tick Tock he's just one of these
characters you know what I mean I feel
cam validated today I feel I feel cured
of histrionic personality disorder after
meeting this guy yeah Jimmy's a kid you
couldn't be from two different worlds
Ethan what were you guys no we are him
and you no we are I'm saying yeah you're
just
okay this is [__] I got it I gotta ask
him about this
is that him that's [__] brother that's
him that's a bit of a thirst trap I
would even go as far as soon
[Music]
he he has his headphones on he can hear
me I know you're listening
okay his whole life is going to the gym
that's pretty he doesn't want to admit
it but yeah his whole life is the gym
okay and so my thing is like the gym is
not like the end-all be-all it's not
going to fix it but that's his whole
life
and that's he married the guy he he's in
a serious relationship I understand it
but he's not married where does he live
if you don't mind me yes I have no idea
okay
I believe Arizona Arizona beautiful
Arizona anybody here from Arizona
extremely beautiful anyone here for
marriage
I think he went to Discord to ask for
meme games uh disses he's like those
Iced Teas
hey dude
so thanks for sticking around I
appreciate it I know it's getting a
little contentious but I appreciate that
we're having this conversation what does
that word contentious mean can you tell
me what that means you've used it
24 years 24 years of wisdom and you
don't know what contentious means it
means we're butting heads
we're butting heads
we're at odds okay yeah argumentative
hey dude look at what their strap did I
post roll this is picture on Instagram
yes dude this is unacceptable
that's a third strap that's like you're
well yeah that was that was before that
was before so 23 weeks how long you been
with your girlfriend about you and it
was also I mean
pretty inspiring I would say considering
I was women can't be inspiring with
their bodies
I mean there's nothing inspiring by
taking off your shirt and showing men
your tits that's what you're doing you
literally just took your shirt off
yeah yeah but the difference is is I
trained extremely hard what about the
girls who trained extremely hard and
then post like Ela is training right now
with a trainer yeah that's exactly what
Eli's photo was that she's showing off
okay I I didn't know that that's great
oh well I think that's super inspiring
that she did that
don't you see how silly you're being you
go oh I didn't know that but it's like
put like everybody who's posting
pictures like there's a lot of them just
feel good they want to show it off well
they're not work there's there's
different contexts right these things
are a lot more nuanced like if you're if
you're just posting a [__] picture
versus if you're like working out and
you're showing your core or like your
progress in the gym like before and
after that's a different concept okay so
Jim probably understand that so good
it's a different context
herself in like tight gym pants and like
a bra lit to show off progress is that
cool or is that slow look I I wouldn't I
still wouldn't want my girlfriend to do
that just in my personal preference
right but it's okay I understand that if
you want to show people your progress
and you're proud of it I'm all about
that
yeah but did you see it's a little silly
because it kind of all qualifies is that
when people want to show off and feel
good
no because we're all working I just
think it's context yeah sure I just
think it's context yeah because this
video you're putting out as the
self-proclaimed role model says women
should not ever do that because that
means they don't respect their man
like this is you as a role model talking
to men
because now you're adding nuance and
contacts and stuff and you're walking
stuff back and you seem more human right
but like when I watch it this this is
this is how I help because that's not
what you're selling that's not what
you're selling of course on I'm not
selling anything yes
I have no control stop it it's your
people no I don't I don't know what
happened to being an alpha male bro you
are don't have control of your own
social media account and the people you
pay I never said I wouldn't want to be
your your incompetent listen
you said you pay this listen you okay
are you done
you said you pay them
yes I do are you done
well now that yes yes please God okay I
never said I was an alpha male I don't
sell any self-help courses I don't do
any of that inspiring okay
I'm just trying to inspire people sure
and I actually forgot what I was going
to say unfortunately but hopefully it
comes back let's go back let's go back
well yeah I mean ultimately
don't you sell courses though about like
being a drop shifter and [__]
so we I'm glad you asked we actually
have a free course you have a free
course people can go in yep people can
go and join that for free we just
launched our first paid course
yesterday so you do sell stuff and
yes as of yesterday I saw a paid because
you just said stuff
I said I don't sell self-help stuff God
Ethan you are so annoying to to argue
with you just because you just like your
ideas are picking up systems you're
you're picking at like the tiny tiniest
little details like that you're just
arguing like such a child no but that's
what it feels like to you but I'm
picking at your logical inconsistencies
because your opinions they're they're
like you would have been a good lawyer
Ethan well thank you now I'm listening
to you but they're they're not small
right am I right or live I just thought
of that they're not they they feel
annoying because like you don't have
adequate answers because your your whole
identity is contradictory you're on one
hand selling this image and you're not
selling it right people don't have to
buy to watch your Tick Tock but you're
branding yourself as a self-help guy and
you put out videos like this about what
women shouldn't candy cannot wear and
then ultimately You're Building yourself
as a personality like Andrew Tate to
sell courses I mean I'm not [__] born
yesterday we all know how it works bro
stop no stop bro why are you pretending
like it's not at the funnel let's not
because I'm I'm not funneling people to
buy my courses I'm yes there are things
that when I speak in these podcasts they
are intended to be a little bit more
polarizing you probably do that too well
that's how you get exposure didn't you
accuse me of being polarizing and that's
why I was a bad dude so hold on you just
said you post pluralizing content
no no I'm saying in those those
instances okay look
if I can't get my thoughts out I'm gonna
lose my train of thought and then if you
won't let me finish speaking I'm just
not going to do it anymore but I want to
finish I want to tell you yes sir
he answered it no okay
so yes in order to grow and a faster way
to grow it you post content and and if
it's controversial then it goes viral
sure and the truth is is that Sebastian
if you watch my longer form content and
if you watch my podcast throughout you
will see and now you see as well
interviewing me that I have a more
nuanced perspective on things and a lot
of the time there's a gray area there's
context and I can understand that so
that's just the truth when people seeing
me and they're like who is this [__]
head they come and watch me on YouTube
and they're like okay or whatever or
they interview me or they watch podcasts
like okay he actually is not people
think yeah she knows a couple of stuff
I'm just using a word do people think
you're a [__] so yes those those videos
do people like you're a [__] well no
I I don't know Ethan I wouldn't imagine
because that's probably something excuse
me of being a bad guy and people don't
like me and that's supposed to be people
think you're a [__]
because you're controversial yes when
when we post these so what's the
difference between what people actually
see me for who I am the difference is
when you actually find out who I am
right I'm a decent person I'm like me
and when people look at you yeah yes
unlike you you're someone that spreads a
ton of hate that's it if someone that is
not an example to follow so the
difference between us is that once you
get to know both of us people will learn
that you're a great guy and I'm still a
piece of [__]
now that's funny but that's what you
said that's hysterical
you're killing me Ethan I just don't
think I don't think there's anything
very inspiring about you right right
I've heard that I'm sorry for it but I
don't and maybe I don't know you that
well maybe there is
uh well people I don't think that there
is that's fine that's fine that's fine
listen uh let's move on right I don't
want to um
I don't want to uh you know here let's
talk about this one can we can we can we
can we find common ground on something
is there anything sorry sorry I think
there is a lot of common ground like we
we have I think there's crossover on
values but these are values that's like
Universal like you don't want your
partner to call you ugly
that's not interesting right that's our
Common Ground well I'm just making a
point there's we have lots of common
ground but that's like normal [__]
right and so
and so I I just you you're branding we
both have good hairlines pull your
hairline back let me see
that's pretty good hair little hairline
very good hairline I'm jealous Dan Dan
I'm jealous
Jersey Outlaws jealous of that hairline
Jimmy hasn't sit this one out
yeah sorry Jimmy he just said you got to
sit this one out
sorry Jimmy I know I'll have Olivia
lower it down a little bit this
have you is are you not like Ethan is
there nothing about what I've done on
the internet that you find inspiring at
all like we what I've done for my family
like what I've done for young men I've
inspired people is none of that
important to you in any way
okay so how did you make money let's
start there
okay so I'll tell you and don't
interrupt me okay I have a video on this
you can watch it for more detail but
I'll summarize it so when I was in high
school I looked on the Internet for ways
to make money because
as you know probably I didn't have any
of it myself so I I I was uh the first
thing I did was I started working at
Taco Bell and then I started working at
a car wash vacuuming cars and then I
started vacuum cars and then I got into
sales and then I got into real estate
and then after real estate I started
doing Drop Shipping that's where I
started Drop Shipping so I would start a
store work on it start another store
work on it and every store that I
started I became better at it I became
more skilled what is Drop Shipping
Drop Shipping yeah you know what Drop
Shipping is I just want you to explain
what it is it's when you buy [__] from
Alibaba and then like resell it on
Amazon supermarked up right
no I mean you buy stuff wholesale and
then you sell it somewhere else you can
attach a logo you can
um create a brand around it there's a
lot of things you could do and it
doesn't have to be cheap products
um and you know what Drop Shipping is
because you have a brand yourself and
you guys Source clothing that is not the
highest quality clothing and you guys
overprice it so you know very well what
this business is and you know how to do
it you think that brand is Drop Shipping
no I think that your clothing brand is
sourced from from China or from
wholesale places that are cheap cheaply
made with cheap quality and then you
sell it overpriced people are better off
just going to h m at the mall and buying
clothes there and plus you do also so
when I was watching hold on hold on when
I was watching this video on you there
was a there was a person that was also
comparing your design and you guys were
stealing tons and tons and tons of
designs from other brands right which in
the past you have also criticized other
people of doing so that's another way
that you're a hypocrite because you
literally say people should instill
designs from Brands and you knocked Drop
Shipping you knocked Drop Shipping
because people you said that people sell
shitty [__] from Alibaba and they
overprice it but you literally do the
same thing with your brand uh Teddy
fresh and I'm pretty sure that's a
pretty large pretty significant source
of revenue for you so I really think it
makes you look bad when you when you say
that kind of stuff but anyway I'm gonna
continue telling my story no no no no
well come on don't be silly now I'm
going to respond to that
so I just want to go back to where this
conversation started you talk about
context and how stupid it is to express
an opinion without knowing what the [__]
you're talking about sure okay
you watch one hater video about how we
still designs and [__] but you've never
heard me talk about that right
no I haven't this is this is all I know
for a minute okay cool so that's not a
very well informed opinion
okay tell me where do you get your your
clothes from
you so so first of all you say that
Teddy fresh is drop shipped you say we
buy no I didn't say that I just said
that I didn't say that
I know you said you just said you did
you said you know what Drop Shipping is
because you do it with Petty fresh you
literally just said that yeah you know
you okay no no you just said you know a
drop that's a fact okay that's not what
I meant okay so you know what Drop
Shipping is because you've explained it
and you know what Drop Shipping is
you've explained it when you were
criticizing me and you do e-commerce
which is very similar to draw all
e-commerce is Drop Shipping that's crazy
so listen are you do you do you have
like what the speaker are the speakers
not working no they work I just think I
just think it's awesome that you speak
confidently with like out knowing
anything which is something that you
criticize people for like you literally
no Teddy fresh how do you think we make
Teddy fresh I will say something you've
just say something and you guys will
take the most like absolute wrong like
you'll perceive it in the most
straightforward absolute way which is so
like what you're doing is just trying as
hard as you can to make me look stupid
and bad it's it's in a form of debate
and it's not like look I'm not here to
do this I'm I'm here to share opinion
where do you get it from you
listen I said yes where do you get your
where do you get your clothes from is do
you not Source it from cheap countries
where do you get it from please if you
don't tell me where let me call do you
think that okay tell me good products
can be made outside the United States is
it possible
yes of course okay so what's your point
where answer me the question where do
you resource it from all over the world
source your clothes all over the world
where where's most of it come from
um
a lot of it's made in China yeah
okay great sure that's where most of
Drop Shipping products are made
of products why is that the same thing
you are just Alibaba is Chinese products
you're not how do you think we make our
clothes how do you think we make our
clothes oh my gosh no seriously how do
you think we make our clothes
tell me I think I think that you steal
designs from other companies and Source
use Source Products from Chinese
countries
okay so and you said it yourself I'm
quoting you you said that drop that's
what they do with Drop Shipping and then
they ridiculously mark it up that's also
what you do your clothing is
ridiculously marked up and your wife has
said that it should be worth more when
it in in reality it's not it's just
cheap clothing there's nothing that
special about let me tell you about that
okay fresh we have 30 employees a huge
design team we design everything in the
studio in our building we Source it we
um we we mock it up it's all original
designs we decide on the Fabrics it's
not all original designs it's on well
you're wrong well you're wrong
um they are all original designs and you
watch one hater's video doesn't give you
an informed opinion to speak that
confidently about it we okay email me
that we design it right in every detail
we do rounds of testing and stuff it
starts in a mock and um we work with
some of the best manufacturers in the
world the same people that make okay so
you Source your products from China you
Source your products from China Drop
Shipping a lot of Drop Shipping comes
from China great so you're knocking it
but you do exactly that and then also
there's nothing I was trying to say is
apple drop ship their phones does apple
drop like iPhones does Apple like I was
trying to does apple drop ship price
this is ridiculous drop ship iPhones
look all right iPhones
because there's shit's made in China
Ethan he's done no I think your brand is
overpriced based on what information is
it overpriced
based on people can go to h m and get
similar style clothing for way cheaper
so forever 21. you you sell hoodies for
a hundred dollars you sell t-shirts any
hoodie have you ever bought a nice
hoodie before
you're saying personal things about my
business and my wife's business so I
have a I have a I'm in full you have to
be protected about the man I'm in a full
right place
by my wife's business as a man Ethan and
it's not just about myself what's wrong
of you I'm showing you how it's wrong of
you to criticize something that I didn't
even criticize it I think it's funny
I just explained it you said it's a scam
I never you said that you said oh you
said you did when you criticized an
alternate reality Drop Shipping is a
scam you said that when you criticized
me go watch the video on me I can't
believe you forgot this I just watched
it two hours ago you said drop you said
Drop Shipping is a scam because you
Source things from China and then you
sell them overpriced and that's exactly
what you why are they overpriced can you
not see the own your own hypocrisy
you're literally being the biggest
[__] hypocrite right now Teddy fresh
overpriced have you ever bought a nice
hoodie before
have you ever touched it have you ever
looked at it do you know anything about
it
he's getting up Ethan I would never pay
a hundred dollars for a design that was
99 inspired from something else that
sourced through from whatever
manufacturer you guys are in the
business of making as much profit as you
possibly can I would imagine okay
that's I think you're knocking something
that you do you're just a giant
hypocrite
all right we're not getting anywhere but
I will say that let me finish let me
finish my story well let me just say
because as a man I need to defend my
wife's company our code is our super
high quality they're made to last
they're made by the same manufacturers
that make stuff like Palace Supreme and
all the top brands it's actually not
super profitable because we put so much
work into the materials and the crafts
our margins are way less than our
contemporaries other brands streetwear
products because they actually charge
more for the same type of product that's
made in the same Factory but because we
know that we don't want to mark it up
too much on our customer we we take it
at less of a margin in fact we're
operating uh we operated on a lot on a
loss last month because
um we wanted to take our time and spend
more time on the design processes and
getting our processes in order with our
30 employees so we did take a loss last
month because we wanted to take our time
and get things going uh organized in an
efficient way like an alpha male would
uh right and so what I'll do is I'll buy
one of these hoodies I'll buy one of
your hoodies I'll have it shipped here
and I'll check it out and then I'll DM
you I'll let you know what I think about
it but okay cool it sounds like you're
gonna have some great great quality
clothing thank you
can you buy one of Ethan Klein's hoodies
for me thank you thank you all right let
me finish telling my story let me tell
you let me tell my story so I got into
Drop Shipping and then I started doing
Ecom e-commerce which is where you
create Brands and you develop like a
whole identity around it and it becomes
a more involved serious thing
um and then once I started to build up
some Capital
um I started just posting my Journey on
YouTube I was like yo guys I grew up
super poor
um there was one point in my life where
my mom couldn't even afford to pay
electricity
um it was always very very bad thrifting
closed just and now I figured out a way
to make some money on the internet this
is what I'm doing so as I was learning
Drop Shipping and Ecom growing my skill
sets my YouTube channel was growing in
tandem with me
um and I built up capital and I started
getting into like trading and I started
doing like investing into stocks and
cryptos and Etc
um
and then my YouTube channel grew and
grew and then I started a agency I
started a marketing agency basically
just running Google ads for Brands
that's what I referenced earlier that
agency I texted my CMO today has
generated 50 million dollars in sales
for its clients and we've gotten we've
worked with billion dollar clients some
brands that you're definitely aware of
um working with their marketing so we've
done that
um and then I continue to trade and
invest I did very very well with trading
very very wealth investing and then of
course the YouTube channel grew we had
an initiative to like grow my personal
brand
um and just and get super big because we
wanted to give back so that free course
that I mentioned is called discover Tick
Tock Drop Shipping
um it's it's like a brochure style it's
not the most detailed thing but it's a
good thing to watch if you're not sure
if you want to get into drop screen or
not it'll teach you the basics and so
the idea is like hey if you like this
you can watch this and there's good
information in here
um based on this information if you
don't like it then you can go a
different way
Sebastian are you a multi-millionaire
hold on yes hold on so that's what I
thought and then that that's what
basically there's like affiliate links
listen I want to let you talk but I
don't need you to explain what affiliate
marketing is
okay so yeah we did that and now that's
doing very very well and then yesterday
because we have a hundred and like 80.
[Laughter]
it's going to be funnier than me that
I'm getting a little jealous oh really
Jimmy yeah no but seriously you you're
monologue you should you should listen
no I'm telling you my story I mean you
should listen to me
it's inspiring I've done very very well
for myself it is inspiring company took
a loss last month it is inspiring you
know who else made a lot of money Jeff
Bernstein
but I'm saying that inherently is is
it's nice that you did that but it's not
enough your your examples are so bad
like I can't believe you're comparing me
to these terrible people I'm not saying
that you do what Jeffrey Sebastian how
many homes how many homes do you have
so anyway I did that and and if you guys
are if you guys are boring and if it's
not interesting no I'm having then
that's fine let me ask you can I please
ask you one thing
who's a better salesman me or you
what do you mean who's the better who's
a better salesman do you think you're a
good salesman
what I don't give me give me what do you
mean salesman in terms of what I'm not
trying I'm not trying it's not selling
yourself yeah yeah yeah yeah selling
yourself you know selling yourself
because obviously
I I'm not trying well Ethan I think I
think I'm I think
I don't think you really even sell
yourself I think that you just make
broad content that that appeals to a
broad audience and that's why you have a
lot of people watching you I don't think
they really think so you're a good
salesman
I don't no I don't know why you're
asking me this question because
I just [__] sold your ass a hoodie
[__] yeah
yeah I know you don't have to buy it
it's still funny
no I'm gonna I'm gonna contribute try to
make your business profitable this this
month because what I my life this is
what I want he has so much money you can
probably buy 20. even I want everyone no
Jimmy shut up I want everyone to do
better in life everyone to be you're a
multi-millionaire you could buy his
company
foreign
the best that they can possibly do in
their life and I know that that's good
for them that's what I want I want you
to make more money I want your company
to be profitable I want you to
I want you to lose weight I want you to
be happy I want you to be the best
version that you can possibly be I don't
care that we disagree on everything I
don't care that you brought me on here
and you're trying to make me look dumb
and it's not working I still want the
best for you and that's how that's my
life
what I want I also so I'm just letting
you know that's no I wish the same thing
not wishing harm for you my thesis is
that you are putting out
I think harmful uh harmful ideologies uh
and and tandem with Andrew Tate you're
riding that wave of red pilling and I
think it's really bad what you're doing
you also well you also call me Dom and
the worst person in the world but we
already went over that we walked that
back so that's fine but um
but this is what I'm saying and we can
get back to that if you want because I
do I do think there's interesting things
like Andrew Tate I'd love to discuss
with you because I know you're a fan no
I'm I'm I'm not red pill at all and I
don't I wouldn't say I'm a conservative
I don't care too much about politics I
literally just want to do my own thing
and I want the best for me and my family
and everyone else in the world that's
all I just want to be left alone I don't
want you to tell me that my kids have to
be gay I want you to just leave me alone
that's all I can I can raise my own kids
so you think people want your kids gay
no I'm just saying I don't I don't want
like I don't want to get into this
because I I'm Frank I don't enjoy
arguing with you because you're very
frustrating I'm just saying I want to be
left alone that's my point
you want to be left alone what does that
mean
it means I don't want people to tell me
like you want to I have to be whatever
my kids have to be gay or whatever I
don't know right but there's an example
saying that right nobody's saying that I
mean that's crazy
well I'll give you an example
if I were to send my kids to public
school I don't want him for my
six-year-old to be exposed to a book
talking about like gay sex or but that's
not happening is it that is that is
happening really where
that is happening look it up I'm I'm
sure there's there's a book that went
viral for like it was in elementary
schools and it was it was teaching kids
about like sex and I just don't want
that yeah you seem to have a really good
grasp on the topic on reality because
you you're you're prepared to home
school your kids because of some
anecdote that you are telling me to
quote look up because you I mean do you
have any other specifics to guide my
research
you could just look it up I'm sure it's
easy to find okay can you guys look it
up
is there an epidemic of six-year-olds
learning about sex it's specifically a
book that is um teaching kids to be gay
are you referring to the books in
Dearborn Michigan Dearborn is it just
something that happened I know you're
from Detroit that's why I asked
hold on no I didn't I've never seen this
in person I've only seen this on the
internet so hope okay well I don't well
you know there's a lot of people who are
scared I've heard that point before it's
like I don't want my kids to go to
public school and then like they become
gay they get tricked to become gay or
trans or something and uh well you say
that there was a six-year-olds learning
about gay sex or something and it's
ruining Society so let's let's look into
that I didn't say that no I didn't say
that no I did not say that I didn't say
that it was ruining Society you're just
you're just like oh my God hold on hold
on hold on you take you you take one
piece of information from what I've said
and then you create like this absolute
version the absolute wrong version can I
play something for you let me play
something that's related I was tanning
and I just heard overheard some kids
talking loudly they were talking about
something transgender or something yeah
I got up and I went I talked to them and
they were like 16 17. and I asked them
I'm like I just have questions oh how
many people are gay at your school like
how many people are in the LGBT
community you say and one kid
immediately said like 60 I was like and
the kid's like no he's exaggerating and
then it's probably like 35 40 and I was
like what are you serious like almost
one almost half and they're like like
almost almost half are transgender okay
and I'm like bro I graduated high school
like four years ago and there was like
three games what happened
yes by the way this is from last year it
says what the f is happening with gay
people 10 years ago everyone called them
F words the F slur for gay people in
high school and today one in six high
schoolers claimed to be gay
one and six so yeah it's continuing more
and more people so do you miss the days
when we could call gay people you know
the f word
no I just think it's surprising I think
it's crazy that that's happened it's
been such a such a popular Trend lately
but that's not true either is it it's
not one in six no it is it is
my cousins that are in high school I've
talked to my cousins in high school I've
talked to strangers that were in high
school that go to my school and a lot of
people liked that video and commented on
it and said the same thing I mean it's a
lot more people are gay and transgender
these days than before and I thought it
was surprising there's such no 30 or
more sometimes there was such a spike in
it which I thought was crazy and
surprising considering gay people can't
reproduce so it's just it's interesting
to see that there's such a spike in it
um and I was curious about it but but
the uh well the obvious answer would be
that it's becoming more acceptable to
come out of the closet so to speak
yeah or yeah it's becoming more
acceptable and it's becoming more of a
trend and more people are saying like
hey this is I don't know yeah whatever I
think it's it's also uh becoming more
acceptable but it's also it's more more
of a trend now you said it's not genetic
sexuality is programmed I wasn't into
girls when I was 12 weeks old right I
mean you're a baby why would you want to
[__] women at 12 weeks if a baby human
was kept in a white room until he turned
18 he wouldn't have a sexuality I think
he'd be [__] brain dead
he would just be an animal yeah no no
yeah I would just demonstrate uh Olympic
Olympic system well there's actually
studies right of when there was like a
wolf girl or something who wasn't
exposed or she was kept in a basement or
something and she lost the ability to
speak so of course they wouldn't have
any sexuality there there was actually
they tried to do the study and it had to
stop because they didn't give any
interaction to the children and the
children would just die even though they
were getting enough food or air like
they just needed affection and love so
that the study couldn't even be finished
I looked it out
so it's too like inhumane so you said
that I tweeted that I tweeted that
because people think they're born gay
and I don't think they're born gay so
people are not born gay they choose to
be gay
I don't think people are born gay yeah I
think that they they choose it's an
important choice yeah I think so
okay and so why would someone want to
choose that especially if you go back
like 20 years ago right like or like you
know 50 years ago uh if you go back all
the way you know Ethan white I read on
that long time ago it's it's guys that
don't have um tight relationships with
their father from what I remember they
end up gay
but I a commonality I saw from when I
was in my 20s because I I was never gay
was like did I say something bad I'm
just trying to help you
okay but I'm not gonna say anything I'm
sorry no no you're good that's just what
I remember I'm gonna go take a piss all
right go ahead I want to unpack this
with you this is interesting
right
oh
who's that
beta
how much longer ease do you keep him on
I see your whole podcast I didn't expect
it to go this long but this is great I'm
enjoying it he says that this is going
to be a life-changing experience for you
do you think it's life-changing so far
um have you seen the light
I'm trying I'm trying yeah looking at
the light but it's too bright
yeah yeah yeah
so uh
who's that any good movies lately
[Music]
these glasses have changed my life can I
okay so check this out here I want to
hit you with something about the gay
thing okay yeah so okay Ethan let's talk
for 14 more minutes and then I have to
go so that's okay that's fair so listen
left-handed people the amount of
left-handed people back in the day was
really low
because people with left-handed were
seen as inferior and they were forced to
use the right hand more often
but as it became more acceptable and
people realized left-handed people
weren't demons then the amount of
left-handed people increased and it
became steady at what like 10 or
something
12 percent is Left-Handed it went up
astronomically all of a sudden what did
it go for from what to what from what
percent to 12 it went from about uh
three percent to 12 so a four-fold
increase four times
wow
interesting and people don't would you
say people choose to be left-handed
uh I don't know I don't know anything
about it yeah but that'd be silly why
would you choose to be left-handed I
don't know I think
it's I mean they could choose to be
left-handed or maybe they I don't know
maybe if you go back what was the night
the Turing guy who invented um he
invented computers yeah he was a
closeted gay man and uh when he came out
he was like lobotomized and ostracized
and yeah so why would someone like that
choose to be gay I wonder
I don't know they felt that they felt
that it was who they truly were inside
probably and that's where they felt
comfortable
yeah maybe some wait if somebody's being
true to their animals how is that a
choice
how is it not I mean they're deciding
that this is this is the the way that
they're going to express like who they
really are this is the this is the what
they're gonna do do you choose for your
data have to be attracted to women
no I wouldn't say so
right
yeah I don't think I I I'm just
naturally attracted to women right
so do I need to connect the dots or you
gotta
let me think about it hold on go ahead
and collect my thoughts
go ahead it's all good take your time
because you're so close you said I
wasn't but the thing is I wasn't I
wasn't born straight though like going
back to the Tweet it's it's something
that I've developed and now that I'm I'm
mature in it and I'm I'm secure in my
attraction to women I wasn't born being
attracted to women I wasn't born with
the sexuality
um and I think that you kind of just
figure it out and then yeah you like
depend based on the way you grow up in
your environment or whatever happens to
you in life you go one or the other way
I I've read a statistic you guys you can
have your team look it up but it's it
was like a majority of people that are
part of the lgbtq have had like some
sort of traumatic um sexual experience
in their life or they have some sort of
traumatic event happening in their life
that uh greatly influences their like
their coming out or their decision or
whatever
um to be whatever it is that they want
to be
um and also although it's a very small
portion of the the population of them
which I think it's like I don't know
maybe I don't know what percent it is
um they are responsible for a majority
of like the the sexual what is the word
um yeah
like sexual cases like molestation like
um sexual abuse cases like they're
responsible for it which would just mean
that it would make sense because if they
were sexually abused then they would be
more likely to sexually abuse I'm sure
you learned that in therapy you think
gay people are more likely to be
abusive to children
sexually abusive I think that's a
statistic yeah I think that's true I
believe so
yeah I'm pretty sure that's not true
because let me ask I'll fact check that
but do kids choose their upbringing
no okay I I don't think so okay kids
don't choose their upbringing and then
they become adults and then they have
this inner commitment they want to be
true to themselves inside them to be gay
so at what point are they choosing to be
gay
you're going to try to frame me as like
someone that doesn't like gay people I
don't have anything against gay people
at all I if someone wants to be gay they
should be gay and that's fine if it
makes them happy then do that I have
friends that are gay so I don't I don't
know like you're in this podcast you're
going to try to make me look bad but
it's not going to work here I don't have
anything against it I'm having a
conversation with stuff you said for
example there's this idea that gay
people are predators that's super
homophobic and actually super wrong
right there's no credible scientific
study or evidence that suggests that
lesbian gay bisexual trans people are
more likely to sexually abuse children
than heterosexual in fact research has
consistently shown that sexual
orientation is not a predictor of sexual
offending of a child
um it's uh State they the American
Psychological Association among other
Professional Organization has stated
that there's no empirical evidence to
support the notion that homosexuality is
a risk for child sexual abuse
so I found a study actually that I read
um that said there's four environments
the child can grow up in right or more
than that but you could have married
male female you could have unmarried
male female married male male married
female female and the the absolute best
case scenario for a child the best
environment was married male and female
um for various reasons and that the
worst environment was unmarried female
and female
um and they reported that they followed
these kids throughout their lives and
they saw that these kids were often more
depressed they had more anxiety they had
trouble paying attention in school and
etc etc
that's true which I don't think it is
bullied for having gay parents
so you should I'll link you the study
and you could read it I don't think it's
necessarily because they get boyfriend
gay parents it could be because the man
gives something that the child needs and
the woman gives something that the child
needs and that's just the best scenario
for the child as it's always been since
the the birth of our species it's always
been this way and that's why it's
probably still the best way right but
I'll send you the study let's assume
that's true like who cares right
whoa you would want your kid to grow up
and not well of course
I [__] my wife and we had a kid
you just wanted to be left alone bro why
do you care
you're asking me that's why I'm
responding okay
what do you do with the data the data
has some application we have we have
seven minutes Ethan is there anything
else you want to talk about can we end
it on a good note or is that is that out
of the question no no no you're right
let's move on let's move on it's not the
it's whatever
um let's see
I want to show you well first okay let's
just do this I know you don't have a lot
of time your thoughts on Andrew Tay real
fast I just want to address this with
you
okay let's do it yeah so just tell me
real fat do you think he's a role model
you think he's a good guy like I just
want to hear you talk about him in short
um if like okay yeah go ahead so I'll
tell you what I think um and please
don't interrupt me so I can get
everything out just try to be successful
okay if you can be because we don't have
a lot of time there are some things
about Tate that are good things that men
would want to emulate and there are some
things that you should not you should
absolutely not emulate there are both
there are bad and good so whatever
that's where I stand so I think so the
good ones
the good ones are obvious like we know
he's like rich and successful and uh
whatever yada yada so what are the bad
ones that's what I'm curious about
okay I starting a uh agency and like an
only fans agency or webcam agency I
don't think that men should ever aspire
to do that ever uh Sleeping with a bunch
of girls and having like all these girls
with you and having multiple wives I
completely disagree with that
um those two things absolutely and then
what else is there
um he's
he's too blunt like he's a little bit
too hard he's he's too aggressive I
think that you need to calm down but I
also think that he is that way on the
internet and in reality he's a lot less
aggressive that's just my what is your
sex trafficker
I don't know I don't know I think that
there is there's a chance that he could
be framed
um uh but also there's a lot of
information that I don't know
um but I don't think him being framed is
crazy I don't think that's completely
out of the question I think that he
pissed off a lot of people and those
people don't want him to talk did you
see the real real quick yes or no did
you see the podcast with Tucker Carlson
and nelcoys
I I know it happened I didn't watch it
okay so in the podcast Tucker talks
about Jeffrey Epstein and he was like
Jeffrey was like he he called his
brother that two days before or
something and he's like uh yeah
Jeffrey's gonna get out everything's
gonna be fine and then boom dead and
that was in like the New York federal
prison which was like one of the most
secure places in the entire planet
um there was like this many inmates that
when they the doors open and they got
out I want to have time to rebutters I
don't want to cut you off yeah go ahead
okay hold on go ahead so he though the
cameras weren't working the inmates got
out Jeffrey Epstein was dead and then
the next day some people were discharged
names were never found nobody knows
anything like this person was killed in
one of the most secure locations
possible nobody knows superficial oh
yeah I believe
I I believe there are people out there
that have some crazy ass power and if
Kate goes against some of the things
that those people agree with I think
that those people have reason to not
like him and reason to try to get him
behind bars were killed I do believe
that so I don't believe it's crazy for
him for him to be falsely accused or for
him to be set up I don't believe that at
all okay he was a framed I mean this is
from this lat just last year you said
Tate is a g brother Jordan Peterson is a
different energy but both together of
the fathers we never had so obviously
you look up to him and you think well
maybe but he's probably framed so I want
to show you a video May I
just okay this is a video it's not it's
not long uh this is a video of from
Hustler University which is his
e-commerce course that was uh
it was uh Unearthed
so let me just play this for you this is
Andrew Tate speaking for himself
oh yeah you're always working I have to
do some traveling and you can't come I
want to bring you with me traveling is a
great one because the thing is about
this business is mobile if you can find
a good Airbnb with good internet you can
run it somewhere else so it's a good
little cabinet to throw in uh you're
always working why don't you work for me
so we spend more time together we're a
few doing walks they'll have a webcam
business oh I don't want to do that so
okay I know you don't want to do that
but listen come let's have a meeting
let's just talk about it we don't want
to do it don't
do it let me explain it to you properly
in fact I'll bring one of the girls who
works for me
you your Bolton [__] the new girl you
go out for [__] a nice dinner your
Bolton [__] is the one who does the
selling you don't do the selling the
girl has to hear from a girl and this is
where your Bolton [__] has to be
trained that's why I said it's so
important to have a good first girl tax
is also another important element of
controlling your woman
you're not going to pay anybody tax es
you're getting paid in Bitcoin so you
don't need to pay tax to anybody you
tell your girl
that you're paying the tax
because girls are lazy your girls are
stupid and girls don't understand how
taxes work
so the girls working with you and you're
like oh okay yeah we've made this much
money but I'm going to pay the tax to
make sure we don't get in trouble
she'll sit there go okay okay
now that allows you to do two things one
is another control element I work with
him my tax is not a problem if I do it
alone I have to deal with taxes taxes
are complicated so control element it
allows you to pay a smaller percentage
so I used to pay my girls 13
so for every ten thousand dollars they
made I give them three and I keep seven
they thought they were on fifty percent
and I said that the disparity is because
of taxes so you're on 50 and we had to
pay the tax first and then it's 50 50.
if they say wide is it 50 50 because I'm
the one on camera you say because I'm
the one typing I'm the one with the
property you're working in I'm the one
paying the bills the electricity I'm the
one who's uh and the electricity and
every other maintenance cost of this
property I'm the one who bought the
equipment I'm the one who knows what
he's doing I'm the one with the
knowledge
shut the [__] up go online
and they should be pretty happy with
that if they respect you as a person
overall
so really you're paying 30 you tell them
you're paying 50. the difference is in
the tax
that's where the disparity lies taxes
if you if they don't believe you or they
want to get fresh or whatever print out
some tax forms I see this all the time I
used to print out some random tax forms
so yeah sign here and sign this what is
it it's for the tax you want to pay the
tax or not
okay and they just signed away I don't
want to [__] sign in let's throw them
away afterwards but they think
something's happening something real is
happening nothing's happening besides me
different HP
was that uh interesting to you what's
your thoughts on that
well I mean
what what do you want me to what do you
want me to say I mean I I don't like
that like I disagree with the way he
talks about it about women in that in
the video for sure do you think well do
you think he was framed after watching
that
well I don't think that
that doesn't provide any evidence as to
into sex trafficking he was just talking
about how he like strong arms and
manipulates women into like working with
him well he started by saying he started
by saying
I bring when well yeah what you just
said is is coercive uh sex trafficking
strong arming and somebody into working
with you that that's the trafficking
part that's that's the strong arms to be
clear that much and I figured out it's
just crap
um
so if I know
well he started by saying I bring a girl
over she doesn't want to do webcam work
so I bring my bottom [__] you know what
that is right I figured it out you know
what a bottom [__] is no it's like your
main prostitute your main sex working
girl who is on your side in terms of
convincing the women and putting forward
narratives and helping keep the women in
check so he brings the bottom [__] they
all go out together he says I have the
bottom [__] explain why it's such an
awesome job to her she doesn't want to
do it at first but we convince her with
this bottom [__] we bring her to my
compound where I steal money from them I
know I know I know I know I know yeah so
that definitely does not that does not
look good for sure like I yeah at least
it doesn't look good
I don't know about you but if I knew
someone that said that [__] I would
[__] I would be I I'm out like I said
I don't I think Kate has some good some
good things about him and there are some
things I don't like about him but that
but don't you think you're putting it
mildly when you go there's some things I
don't like about him because what he
just said is he's admitting to several
crimes and I know Seth's trafficking
maybe is not sometimes as obvious as
people think but he did describe what
sex trafficking is is he in jail right
along for how long well his trials on
he's been detained for for he keeps he's
in detention but his trial hasn't
happened yet but he's locked up he's
locked up so he's so you're safe because
he's not around I'm safe not you I mean
people are safe the women are safe yeah
so G Lane was Epstein's bottom [__]
yeah
it's almost three minutes
um
I that doesn't look good just to finish
that off it it's yeah it's pretty shitty
by him in my opinion and
I don't think anyone should look up to
that part of him at all for sure that's
that's definitely validate the good
parts
I think I mean you can you can pick
things from people and you can take the
good things and leave the bad but yeah
um he's jacked and does karate can
I mean and he's motivates people to get
in the gym and yeah yeah but he also sex
trafficks women
but he goes to the gym but he's he we're
all gone he's cool
a lot of people say Hitler was a great
uh I hate to go back but you know it's
just so easy Hitler was a you know he
did all kinds of he motivated people he
really did motivate people but but he
was a bad person
I I told you I have to go and I wanna I
wanna wrap it up I love raping you to a
woman who accused him of rape that's a
li that's a WhatsApp text obtained from
a subpoena
[Music]
um
okay yeah
can we
wrap it up or or do I have to leave
uh we can wrap it up well I do want to
say I appreciate all the time that you
spent here with us thank you thank you
not expect it to be this long yeah I
appreciate it we had a lively
conversation we had a contentious
conversation you learned a new word
today I never I never finished my story
either Ethan you never let me finish my
story go ahead
well I don't have time now but you can
watch my videos
I don't think it's that interesting you
said you would change my life do you
think that you've achieved
I don't know I think that we're gonna
need multiple sessions we don't have to
record them but you could give me your
phone number I can call you and we could
talk more do you really think you can
help me that you have knowledge that you
can motivate me
absolutely yeah absolutely I think I
could open up your mind
right 100 and you know you know about
you know that I'm like
you know like I'm the traditional male
that you dream of dude I'm married I've
got kids I'm rich I run my own business
don't you think you should be asking me
for advice
no no but I I am the traditional because
you're fatty but you don't go to the gym
yeah you're fat well that's it there are
some things I could probably learn from
you but no there's there's definitely
things you could learn you value
monogamy
heterosexuality children and well all
right I have all those things Ethan you
could learn more from him no you could
learn more from him Olivia and I we we
agree on that one note right here's my
words of wisdom you're a 24 year old you
don't know [__] about life as all 24
year olds you have hubris that's your
downfall you would be so much more open
receptive and respectable if you had
some
um humility exactly you need to have
humility I have more humility I have
more humility than you do do you see
what he's such a hypocritical thing to
say literally just did it you're one
upped I said I have more humility than
you don't you see that that's an ironic
statement you are being such a hypocrite
unbelievable you said I have more
humility than you like do you see how
stupid that is
like you you're into all of your content
is hateful how can you go see more
humility
I'm a comedian look at look I oh my God
all right I'm inspiring men I'm
inspiring men I tried to to wrap it up
and like finish off on a good thought to
literally be more mature than this
nearly 40 year old person here that
invited me and you're not having this
I'm already I'm already 52. well the
difference is quite apparent but I do
wish for you I I'm going to leave
I just want to keep going like a little
child more humility give us a flex to
end it on a good note give us a flex
let's see the muscles Flex us up
take the shirt off let me see the pack
work
brother
see you later my friend all right we can
talk again soon yeah maybe we will
actually but I appreciate you spending
the time and sitting through it all so
thank you man appreciate it really do
have a good night all right take care
recording stopped here it is
I don't know I don't know if he knew
that was live because he recorded
the zoom well he I would be surprised if
he didn't know because he seemed to do a
lot of research watching like two hate
videos on YouTube about you before
coming into this call he knew about he
knew a lot about you yeah but he doesn't
know anything like but he thinks he
knows everything I wonder if he's gonna
if he's gonna watch that back he thought
he looked I listen I mean first of all I
would you say I do respect that he sat
through that whole thing more than I
would say you were you were killing I'm
surprised you didn't bail on you I
thought he hung him he hung in I thought
he was going to go to the bathroom and
never not come back yeah
this is going to be cut into a million
different ways as Tick Tock uh Sigma
grind set videos you know I knew going
in this is going to be like a thousand
Alpha Sebastian owns Ethan compilations
I'll counter them with uh the the other
way there you go
it's crazy how he's more critical of you
than uh Andrew Tate a confirmed sex uh
yeah he he made you sound worse than
Andrew Tate yeah they have such a hard
time
um
denouncing him like they cannot like I
showed him a video of Andrew tape being
like I am evil and I heard people
I don't know buddy acknowledged that
yeah after you showed him that video on
the sex trafficking thing that's
I did that with Dan years ago we figured
that out to stop in the early 90s right
no there's no accidents you just tried
to be
no idea
no I defendant did it don't accident
Jimmy you've done good today I can't
even lie about it I've been great yeah
he's been great
yeah
I'm being serious and you had some great
commentary throughout oh you were
cracking me up I appreciate a shout outs
I love it you did good actually it was
really fun having you uh outside there
being normal well I didn't want to say
it on the ear and hurt the guy's
feelings my God that was yeah yeah
the guy was so off but I didn't want to
say nothing to the kid Jimmy you were
cracking me up when you took a bathroom
break you came over here and you
whispered to me this guy's full of [__]
what has a 24 look I'm older comfortable
you're middle-aged way comfortable this
kid's 24. and if you look at the
background where he lives and he's
telling you multiply this isn't a hard
one to figure out you think his
apartment didn't look expensive
my goddamn room in a hotel where I'm
staying I don't live it is nicer than
that I mean it's not a hard one to
figure out if you let people Lin always
says if you let people talk and you
don't say anything in about 10 15
minutes you could figure it off that's
Jimmy quoting his that's my smart wife
Lynn who listens and is so smart she
knows feminist King yeah you are a
feminist King yeah my wife's my wife's
uh as I said to uh Ethan I have to say
she's one or four I'm out of the will
you know have to be careful everything's
in her name again I said I have to be
careful what I say or I'm out of the
will everything's in her name all right
don't push don't push no but uh I don't
think he understood honestly he's a kid
he doesn't understand it's just it's
just but he's trying so hard to be
compelling but I mean an older person
like me can see through that the whole
hard to figure that the whole thing
about like Teddy fresh being Drop
Shipping I can't believe how he insulted
your brand I'm surprised you didn't
caught her he was so insulting about
your wife and your brand and that's fine
I heard that [__] all the time it was
just a bizarre point to be like he knows
the difference between manufacturing
overseas and Drop Shipping like yeah but
it's like we're not buying our clothes
on Alibaba
already made right yeah I mean you made
a good point does apple drop ship their
iPhones yeah like because they're made
like that that was a great Counterpoint
that you made there
I just didn't seem to really get through
I think he was angry and he was just
trying to hurt yeah I got problems we
got to let him have because he actually
has problems what do you think eth give
him that quote I've got problems he's
got problems he's got real I got
problems he's got problems no no my
problems are my jokes his problem he's
really got problems he is a problem he
is a problem
oh
yeah I don't know was that good I mean
we were trying to I went for a long
while people seem to love it um Hassan
was messaging me throughout that whole
thing saying what a great job you were
doing oh thank you yeah I'm just
watching it on stream oh thank you bro I
appreciate it I think if I'm not
mistaken at one point he said okay Ethan
I'm not even kidding no I called it yeah
no Ethan pointed it out yeah we got a
new one yes there we go he did there's a
sound bite of someone else I was
debating okay Ethan and he said that at
a point of when he was too frustrated
with me to to
to counter my point he did the same
thing so why would he want to come on
when he when he doesn't like your
content he doesn't like you because he
he thinks you're your your business that
makes a fortune is a scam like why would
I that's all Preposterous so I am kind
of like a meme on Tick Tock amongst
alpha males because there's a clip of me
making fun of the gym whatever that's
taken out of context is that how that
started yeah and so to them again this
video he thinks he's smarter than me and
he thinks he's better than me and he
thinks he's going to come on here and
make me look like a fool
and it's again it's the hubris I mean he
actually published this video on his
channel and this is I saw this and I was
like please God call into the show
really stupid Ethan Klein he's stupid
the worst person oh the worst person
he's the worst this is my favorite he
wishes he was us this man he wishes
who's that who's that I don't know it's
his little it's his Sidekicks
so I really wanted you to ask him about
this but in
correct me if I'm wrong but he hosts
that show with another guy named
Sebastian
what I don't know it's two sebastians is
that a problem it's just [__] weird
right like what oh how many sebastians
by the way they got two I had something
funny I wanted to point out to him uh
but we just kept getting so sidetracked
but I wanted to show him in this clip
where he goes I was shocked about so
many gay kids he starts It Off by I was
tanning and I mentioned what he says in
the beginning I just was like oh [__] he
goes listen to this
I was tanning and I just heard I was
tanning broken
you were tanning bro so you think he's a
lemon dropper
I'm just making fun of the fact that uh
he he's tanning what are you what are
you gay
I was tanning and I just heard overheard
something
[Music]
thank you
okay
it's always fun uh it's always a good
time
I just surprised you so call he called
you a slight too kind of got her a hoe
dressing like a hoe I was getting so mad
yeah Olivia you said something nice I
heard what you said about that she
trained and stuff yeah but he he goes
you're nitpicking but I'm like no I'm
pointing out logical inconsistencies
that you know you're not willing to
confront yeah he says hoe dressed like a
hoe but it's different when guys it's
like a workout sweatsuit that was pretty
brutal it's different when guys do it
because we're just checking out our
gains yeah I mean what are you talking
about dude
yeah
there it is
all right
thank you Hassan I appreciate that
Hassan you're the man you're you're a
great dude I love you and I'm excited to
see you tomorrow
you know Jimmy did so good today I'm so
proud of you I wasn't sure you were
going to make it no I do to keep quiet
and just be a commentator Jimmy for
permanent co-host
like the Ed McMahon don't punch don't
push because I said oh would you would
you move out to LA to be my permanent
co-host I should move at it because I I
like the entertainment field in the
other field you know Hollywood I like it
out here better I'm older I like this
would your family move out here would
you that's the whole thing Lynn's
staying right where we're at that's the
whole that seems like a challenge that's
uh Lynn runs the show there so I gotta
just come visit and have fun but come a
little more often yeah which is what
I've been doing well I'll tell you what
after today you're welcome to sit in
with us anytime oh give me a hug
[Applause]
yeah you too you have a heart of gold
I'm a good guy I wouldn't I wouldn't
hurt I come off rough with the car I
wouldn't hurt a fly oh I know that I
know that you're sorry
and that's what I wanted Dan to know
because Dan kept texting me how much he
hated me and I wanted to say Dan I love
you and then Dan said we have a lovely
relationship you love me has he grown on
you Dan after today a little bit I like
I said when he walked in I do not have
any issue with Dr wink doctor he said
with Dr Weider I have an issue Jimmy Lee
give me the Jersey Outlaw the Jersey
Outlaw but come on I mean Jimmy you know
this like you your whole like thing is
like I'm edgy I'm say wild stuff and
like naturally not that's not
everybody's gonna like it that right I
know that's that's okay you know what's
interesting you are funny
when you're like dude I don't know [__]
and even without he was describing sex
yeah that was hilarious oh I figured it
out after a minute because I'm listening
but uh
that was just funny but see you're just
by accident almost yeah but the whole
shtick I don't I don't think it's as
funny as you are you know what I
realized is I talked to Jimmy more than
I talk to my own grandma
Zach I guess he's going to meet me
tomorrow for dinner
don't don't push I thought you were
gonna make it like a now we went on a
vacation everybody no I'm not allowed to
do jokes here Dan Dan's gonna beat me if
I do you're so much funnier when you're
not allowed to do jokes
there goes the sound bits
let's see if there's anything else we
want to go through today that was a long
yeah we're at three hours just uh heads
up man you sat through three hours oh
that's nothing I want to know Zach where
we're having dinner tonight
um
[Music]
he just folded his hand Heath on that
one
this is awesome how it started I'm going
to change your life how it ended I just
want to be left
I was like feeling that hysterical oh
yeah he was how's he gonna let me hear
some how's he changing people's lives at
24 years old I want to know what he's
doing but like I have every Tony Robbins
is actually a motivational speaker he's
actually good what is this guy doing to
change and motivate you he's going to
teach people how to I sit on Alibaba and
sell them how to drop ship yeah
okay
I mean that's is you buy [__] on Alibaba
and you sell it on Amazon right I mean
that's what it is I mean in a nutshell
in a nutshell I'm sure there's other
nuances to it and maybe not all from
Alibaba or whatever but yeah I mean Buy
Low selling it's crazy that Toyota just
drop ships cars over here
I mean they should get a real job
you know
[__] that man I'm not buying any of
those drop ship Toyotas I'm waiting for
my new Thief I'm waiting to wait for my
new car because I have to order it you
can't even get caught Mercedes course
now oh really drop ship them over no
they have to order it and it takes
months for them to get it because you're
waiting for a new car for six months I
think I'm getting in a month what'd you
get the uh the amg's are nice thank you
oh good for you cylinder but they got
the turbo which model C or E not the big
expensive one the one that's like 80. a
little much you got the C-Class it's an
AMC so it's a Mercedes sports model car
it's an AMG or AMC do you see my car out
there I think you might like it the
rolls the all no I I returned that
monstrosity I did the same thing I
didn't like driving so stupid isn't it
too big it draws too much attention
people keep looking yeah and I had to
put the cover on it and I took it back
and I actually got a profit on it meet
somebody wanted a crazy 30. I got 30 on
the court they gave me sixty thousand
dollars to break my lease oh you had a
leash I paid and the guy Kerbeck I see
him at I see him at uh isn't the
restaurant somebody wants that car we
don't have them I said I'll bring it
right over to you I didn't want that
yeah yeah I had to pour like six months
drove it five times I couldn't drive the
car it's like a boat yeah it wasn't me
yeah that's how I felt too so you could
have money you don't need a Rolls-Royce
you really don't right that's funny you
returned it you made money on it that's
crazy isn't it I was like man I'm gonna
take I'm sure which is Black or White
there's black pulling in
the same as me we're so alike we are man
Sebastian's just [__] the bed
there was 43 000 people watching
the funniest thing you guys did was when
he was in he was really insulting you
and you put the screen up where his
followers went in the crapper that was
that was that was the funny timing on
that was pretty was that you Dan that
was uh I know somebody else pulled that
up yeah I didn't even know what to say
that was funny yeah I looked it up
immediately and yeah sure yeah I can't
provide well Dan you're you're good on
your your research God you're quick it's
a good team we got here yeah you're
really a good team you have a loyal team
it's incredible anybody watches the show
come on we're all good team going down
it's a shame no men watch the show
though right you know what he didn't
have like the most popular podcast of
all time like one year ago hey Eve it
doesn't matter if you have women man
half half whatever you have a huge fan
base I like half half and it would be
it'd be nice that the guy says dude
you get over a million followers uh
views uh that's that's crazy it doesn't
matter who's watching you got so many
people watching you a fan is a fan it
could be a kid could be an adult be a
man or woman you got people watching you
got a ton of people people are saying 80
000 if you count Hassan oh that's a good
point you know because he had like 35k
more importantly I think he should be
asking why his audience is so male like
why are women so repulsifier that's why
he's a chauvinist you know where he was
going carefully and how he feels he's
very the old school Europeans that's how
a lot of the men are they're they're and
you know what very old school
he's from Romania if you have a
relationship with your significant other
where you guys like that kind of
relationship then that's then that's
awesome well that's that old school
European man woman relationship my
problem is that he presents this as a
self-help guy that this is the way to
live and it's not no you know it's not
you're right thank you I just love that
based on his content he thought you'd be
a layup and then he got here and got
[__] slammed yeah do you think he
knew he wanted to get hammered that bad
I don't think so I don't think he would
come on if he did he also got ratioed on
that tweet I'm just looking at it well
we have all of our fans I mean yeah what
he goes your Tweet got no likes I was
like what the [__]
and also who cares yeah and also why are
you arguing about Twitter likes
oh man that was good could I ask who did
my design because it's really good with
the Rickles and the tooth and the uh cam
cam you're incredible okay you're so
good do you want to hire him for your
social media team Jimmy well how do I
hire me works for him there you go I
couldn't afford any of you guys I'm
doing it as a as a as a fun thing this
is your job you're paying your people
like I pay my dental people bro they got
real jobs yeah they make a lot of money
yeah Jimmy you know I toss you a bone
every now and again I know you do I know
you by the way I love the way you guys
melded the green screens together so it
looks like one coherent kind of bleed
that's awesome yeah we and the last time
that you had a coach what's that picture
of on the desk that we just left it on
the green for comedic effect but um I
like this yeah this this seems nice Kim
what's the picture next to the phone
that's your family photo it's all of us
it's the other podcasts on your desk I
have another family again so I have I
have to move out here come out here more
often I have two families
I'll tell you just tell your wife and
kids my room I have another down in
California my real family's the
Peninsula Hotel on 8th Street
my wife will go for that she'll say go
uh oh boy well I think we'll be back in
the summer okay knowing knowing the
family trip this is March yeah well also
Jimmy won his prize right I mean he got
through the whole episode
so do I get to do that oh yeah Zach told
me driving here yeah yeah you you won
the grand prize it's a live show uh we
don't have a date yet but there'll be
1500 people there so what I will do this
year I will promise you
I won't
go away a month before and they're not
coming as long as you give me the notice
I'll make sure that I next time I come
it'll be when you it'll likely be in
like mid to late May is what it looks
like so you mean it's going to be soon
relatively soon all right well then mid
to late May so we'll see it's all still
in the works and it's okay I only say
because I noticed summer trips like in
July June or July August so I'll come
out maybe for a short trip but I'll come
out for that because I messed up the
last one then because what I did was I
came November I remember my publicist
got me all this crap and then I just
couldn't come back a month later I
couldn't afford it makes sense we'll
plan it a little bit all right all right
yeah yeah but if you give me notice I'll
come even if I come just for you we
expected that 10 million of the same
texts
thanks for the 50 gifted 50 gifted not
another 50. thank you says I want 100 to
thank either me and open minded willing
to learn a compassionate role model I
look forward to tuning in every episode
thank you for being you okay you must be
lying nobody looks up nobody looks up to
Ethan lost my train of thought another
50 gifted thank you
dude you got ratioed by Jimmy Lee bro
look at this I had to do it too I had to
do it to him love who's that this is him
he tweeted that and it's Jimmy's saying
ratio
it means you got more likes than he did
under his tweet I got more likes him on
his tweet yeah that's insane ratio and
he's got the picture when I was on the
boardwalk all right Jimmy I gotta show
you how to unmute your phone wait wait
wait oh yeah please I'm a long time
history fan Gabe not by choice and
disagree with much of what you've said
but I very much respect you even going
on the show
and even play saying goodbye respect
okay we love our nice fans I thought we
were all hateful piece of [__] Trolls
but women who wrote that a fan a fan
said I disagree but I'm glad you're
respectful he said that's what's up the
only person from Ethan's audience that
has been nice
well at least there's one of them
so there you go
but it's like you know it's like
something's just
some things he doesn't understand what
he's doing he does too he's young I
understand he doesn't know what he's
saying he's trying to say he doesn't
know what he's saying yeah
what do you know with 24. I'm I'm older
I I still I was telling uh one of your
guys earlier I still need to learn a lot
and I'm older I still learn every day
you just learned what a ratio is yeah
there's so much I don't know when I'm
older and I've traveled all over and I
got a business and this gives 24 ton he
knows everything
well here's here's what I want to do
Jimmy For Old Times Sake we have the
giant cane we didn't get to use it but
what do you say we we hook you off stage
just for old time's sake I want to do it
like the time we did before yeah just
for you're not being actually caned off
but just like caned off but you want to
do it but if somebody help me with my
phone so yeah he has well hold on hold
on yeah ABS booked the cane and he's
being dragged up so long
wait a minute you're gonna bang my leg
see you
well that's Jimmy Lee everybody he's the
man
oh Lord oh my God Jimmy's so interesting
he wins you over one week he loses you
all the way the next week it's a roller
coaster
oh
Jimmy asks who's gonna unmute me uh AV
has stepped in to be that sweet kid
he's screaming did anyone get pictures
of us
we told you after the show Jim
well what a terrific audience uh what a
terrific crowd a treasure
and respect for staying so long
absolutely I mean yeah he did a marathon
with us that was good man
that was good
here this is 40 seconds ago he's Jimmy
and ab we we are still hey can you guys
escort him to uh please leave the studio
for your conversation thank you so much
uh Sebastian is coping he says here
comes Ethan's fan to clown on me I was
actually trying to find common ground
with him but he wasn't having it didn't
know it was going to be live
again bro that's kind of on you
literally why did you not know that like
that's our thing also it's live on
YouTube right now
didn't know it's going to be live also
said they weren't trying to gotcha me I
did not gotcha him did I I was engaged
lots of humility
I did not got you him did I list a list
of his content that you wanted to go
through with him and whenever you
stopped on something very specific I
think he would get frustrated because
you wouldn't keep going but you were
curious about specific ideology that
went into what he said in that exact
moment but he didn't he didn't want to
get into it he's not used to being
challenged or pushed back on at all yeah
he took that as being
um well in other words immature but I
mean I don't think you were really being
immature perhaps a few moments here and
there I dare you I mean me the great
role model people cry when they meet me
Dan how dare you
but I would say we gotcha Jeff when we
had that picture I did not gotcha him I
wanted to have a conversation he asked
me what's contentious for me
gotcha I don't think you yeah I think he
more inspired him I think he changed his
life for the better
he'll come to learn he'll cry when he
sees me I'm sure of it
he's gonna come to my next fan meet up
and cry and talk about how he changed
his life
mm-hmm
um also you've got to love how he's like
I'm more I have more humility in my
pinky than you'll ever I'm the most I'm
the most humble person you've ever
[__] met it's so funny it's like a
meme I mean it's like what the [__] yeah
that was yeah
okay it's kind of sad to how desperate
he is to get validations from his
success story too it's kind of
embarrassing in my opinion like Toronto
oh my God and what a boring
the reason I kept interrupting him is
because he just wants to like do this
puff piece and he keeps talking about
the same thing about how I'm so rich and
I'm so inspiring and yada yada it's like
bro I you know let's just have a
conversation about the points
uh that that are interesting
you know
there it is huh
Jimmy you can stick around if you want
to say goodbye you can actually come
back I was just doing stick
yeah you can come back you want to come
sit down
yeah it's fine yeah I was just I just
wanted to pull you off with the can uh
it's fine come join us
you know
he's getting his formal glasses
Kimmy's coming back all right are you
struggling with that yeah but you know
okay I'm back Jimmy's back so go ahead
you want to sign off we can sign off now
Jersey Outlaws back
I thought I was I thought I was leaving
well we are leaving we are leaving we
are leaving
again wait wait wait wait wait wait it's
a [__] I thought Sebastian said he had
somewhere to go where what's he doing
you want me you want to hook me again
Twitter maybe am I getting hooked again
I think he's busy the way Elon Musk is
busy right another Sigma grind male
Sigma grinding from the John baby
he cannot unders he cannot understand
that I am the real Sigma grind Alpha I'm
traditional as a [__] guess and sat
in fact some people call me Ethan when
you're when you're real successful you
don't have to explain to people that
you're successful some people call you
you don't have to explain to people or
when you're where you're at like what
Lynn and her dad always said no wait a
minute he's being canned off again
and save me it's Dr Weiner Man Dan
bye Jimmy we'll see you next time I love
you guys love you buddy be good okay
and Jimmy you'll send the Oxycontin 100
milligrams to my Pharmacy right
[Laughter]
joking that's a joke
just kidding guys
yeah you don't have to run out
he is being played off though
I hate to say goodbye we've had such a
good time today
but it is that time wait we had we
wanted to make a little mini
announcement
about
here about the uh lore yeah
Okay so
yeah we had a lot of feedback about the
lore series
and we're thinking of changing the
approach to be more comprehensive
um so
the first video
we're going to go back and do it on Zach
and we're creating a comprehensive list
of all his acts Greatest Hits and stuff
and we're it's probably gonna be like an
hour long video maybe even more I don't
know where it's like here is all the
Zach memes and history you need to know
so it would be helpful because there's
so much content dude like I can't
remember the [__] we've done
and we've generated our list as best as
we can but if you're in Discord or I
don't know where's the best way for I
think the best way to do it is to post
to Reddit and in fact cam you uh created
a special Flair for this right you think
that's the best way Reddit yeah I'll
just make a like he's helping me to his
car okay yeah yeah so so just so because
I don't want to miss stuff and there's
so much stuff yeah so um in the coming
days if you are a Zach Lewis fan
um or just it more generally a fan of
this podcast and you have iconic Zack
moments that you would hate to see left
out of the story of Zach which that's
really what it is it's going to be a
documentary of Zach's time on the issue
dreams coming true so if you yeah you
have some obscure I mean
and with peace and love there's the
obvious ones The Joker brain the he
loves mayo and all that but if there's
something more obscure or something that
you think could easily be overlooked but
is to you an icon exact moment post to
the sub we'll be looking forward leave
it alone
yeah sometimes we miss the obvious ones
too if you have a timestamp to it that
would also greatly help oh that's
amazing I mean if you really want to be
a legend time stamp that ship for us so
that we know exactly what it is that
you're talking about we can rip it and
incorporate it into the video thank you
yeah and so this is going to be we're
going to do like a long-term uh project
here it'll be take a couple weeks
probably to do it and yeah I think
that's the other thing is we were we
were trying to crank them out on a
weekly schedule which is you know great
and people most of our content is weekly
and they're used to that but um I think
just after reevaluating all the feedback
we got we think it would be better to
just take our time to let them marinate
and and make them right so we're gonna
redo the Dan one because I agree the
approach in that video wasn't wasn't the
right way to do it so
um we'll come back to me well we're
going to come back we're going to do it
all over we're going to start all over
by the way uh Harvey
uh first of all I want to say about this
Sebastian on Twitter says did the best I
could these comments and DMS are so
insane I can't believe it don't please
don't harass him you know he's going to
come to terms with I think he left that
thinking he owned me
and and let's just I want I want him he
doesn't need to be harassed don't be
mean if you want someone to learn they
won't learn right it's true show him the
H3 fans are nice prove to them that
there's more than that one person
five-time coveted Survivor be be
generous to him
that's funny
this man's got so much long covet as
[__] his brain has turned into a
razor I would explain that a few things
do one more and he'll be the Michael
Jordan the coven that's right right
double three p yep uh but I do think
it's funny what Harvey
wait hold on let me go back
I like this cope though even though
I do want him not to be uh Ryan Harvey
uh left us a response to this tweet
where he says everyone's being mean to
me
[Music]
foreign
Zach was dipping it out
oh [__] oh that that'd be [__] up we
got it we'll chill the chestnuts is the
same amount of time or what we just
played yeah so you never know probably
okay he was right on two seven seconds
yeah that was good this man asked me
with the straight face what does
contentious mean
he's young it's not but yeah but you
know not that advanced of a vocabulary
world but he opened with I'm I have
wisdom I have wisdom coming out my ears
brother a Wazoo I got wisdom for days
boy isn't wisdom by definition like like
not like knowledge through lived life
like that generally seen that way I mean
a young person can be wise uh which was
a point he was trying to make at one
point which I think is fair I don't
necessarily know if he's an Exemplar of
wisdom but it uh because wisdom is the
quality of having experience and
knowledge it's like you know it's it
means specifically that you've lived a
life and you have wisdom from these
lived experiences you could be smart you
could be insightful you could be
intuitive
oh but it's a little bit
hubris for the young person to say
they're wise
oh that could be good Chad says that was
smart button for dmca next time that's
fine yeah that's true well we can always
cut it if it gets cool yeah we'll just
cut it up
hey Jim I didn't get a flag on the back
end by the way so I think we're okay
wow what a show guys who says that who
says this podcast is on the decline who
Ethan decline where Ethan incline oh
Ethan declining
if this is your first time watching feel
free to hit that subscribe button turn
on those Bell notifications that's right
give this vid a thumbs up
oh yeah hey you know um another
surprising thing about that interview is
that Jimmy didn't know what a rim shot
was
this is the Old Timer was baffled by
that you're the old tiny comedian like
Rim shots are of his error that's it
that's that's all it is right it's a rim
shot after Rim shot
hey he uh was talking to me for five
minutes in the parking lot he says he
loves us all yeah thanks for coming for
all of the you know Jimmy's
yeah he is a really a sweet guy he asked
me three times when the live show was I
told him we'll let him know okay but let
me know when the live show is we'll let
you know as soon as we know you'll know
definitely let him know but I got it I
gotta know six weeks in advance so you
let me know yes Jimmy I'll let you know
Zach is good I love you guys everything
in his power to play us the [__] off
right I have to you know that still
it's like a racehorse he's been making
the music well he's like all right here
we go thank you Alexandra for the five
gifted guys we'll see you tomorrow
morning for leftovers we're a great
friend Hassan and the savior of animals
this man save dogs
[Applause]
uh wait hold on chanting Karis Mao said
I'm really happy y'all are challenging
the red pill uh Sigma narrative YouTube
continues to push it on me and I can
only imagine how it would influence me
if I was a younger person
that's what we're doing here you
presented him with his own content and
that was a gotcha bro also I'd be I'd
bet money he owns Supreme and has no the
nerve to diss Teddy fresh that was my
point I know you own designer hoodies
bro that cost a lot more than 100 bucks
because you're on the status symbols I
bet you you've got like a thousand
dollar hoodie from like vitamins or
whatever that you [__] you know
I just want to acknowledge all of our
great supporters he drives a Lamborghini
right or what was the deal with that
what was it a Lamborghini I have to pee
okay we're gonna call it a day we'll see
you guys tomorrow for leftovers thank
you everybody fantastic episode thank
you for being here everybody
[Music]
foreign